BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR
ON STATE ADMINISTRATION.
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SENATORS PADILLA,
PRESENT. NILO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEE?
WELCOME FOR EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION TODAY, WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT THE ITEMS DOCKETED
UNDER ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION,
WHICH ARE ISSUES, 13 THROUGH 31.
STARTING OFF WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. OUR
PRESENTERS. I KNOW WE HAVE
DEPARTMENTS PRESENTING, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SQUEEZE
EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE. I'M TOLD
, AND SO TRY TO MAKE YOURSELF
COMFORTABLE, AND WHEN YOU DO,
JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
DEPARTMENT FOR THE RECORD AND
PROCEED WHEN READY. WELCOME. HI.
JT CREEDON WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE THE
SALES AND USE TAX, BAD DEBT
DEDUCTION AND REFUND FOR LENDERS
AND AFFILIATES BEGINNING IN
JANUARY 2025. CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW ALLOWS RETAILERS, LENDERS
AND RETAILERS AFFILIATES TO
CLAIM A REFUND OR DEDUCTION FOR
SALES AND USE TAX RELATED TO
TRANSACTIONS FINANCED WITH LOANS
THEY ISSUED OR REQUIRED UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES, AS LONG
AS THEY EXPENSE THE BAD LOAN ON
THEIR INCOME TAX FILINGS.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA LAW ALSO
ALLOWS RETAILERS TO CLAIM THE
SALES TAX DEDUCTION, OAN IN THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CASES, CONSUMER
LOANS ARE OFFERED NOT BY THE
RETAILER SELLING THE GOOD, BUT
BY LENDERS SUCH AS BANKS, CREDIT
UNIONS AND OTHER FINANCIAL
COMPANIES, MEANING THESE
ENTITIES ARE ULTIMATELY THE
PRIMARY BENEFICIARIES OF THE BAD
DEBT DEDUCTION. ACCORDING TO
CDTFA. THE BULK OF THE BAD DEBT
DEDUCTION REFUND DOLLARS ARE
CLAIMED BY LARGE COMPANIES, SUCH
AS CREDIT CARD COMPANIES AND OR
FINANCING BANKS OF AUTO
MANUFACTURERS. THE DEDUCTION
GIVES A DOUBLE BENEFIT TO
LENDERS, LOAN OFFERS TYPICALLY
INCLUDE INTEREST PAYMENTS AND
LATE PAYMENT PENALTIES. AS
CONDITIONS OF THE LOAN, LENDERS
EVALUATE AND PRICE THE RISK OF
THE DEFAULT TO DETERMINE THE
INTEREST RATE THEY CHARGE WHEN
THEY DECIDE TO ACCEPT THE RISK.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PERCEIVED
BY THE LENDERS AS RISKY
BORROWERS ARE OFTEN CHARGED
ELEVATED INTEREST RATES, WHICH
CAN BE 30% OR MORE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT AND COMPENSATE LENDERS
FROM THE COST OF A POTENTIAL
DEFAULT. ADDITIONALLY, THESE
INTEREST PAYMENTS ARE CALCULATED
ON THE TOTAL PURCHASE PRICE OF
THE TAXABLE ITEM, WHICH INCLUDES
SALES TAXES, WHICH BENEFITS THE
LENDER THROUGH HIGHER INTEREST
PAYMENTS. IN EFFECT, THIS LAW
PROVIDES AN UNNECESSARY SUBSIDY,
OR A DOUBLE BENEFIT TO LENDERS,
AS LENDERS ARE CURRENTLY ABLE TO
CLAIM THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION
EVEN IF THEY RECEIVED THE
INITIAL LOAN AMOUNT AND MADE A
PROFIT ON THE LOAN THROUGH
INTEREST AND PENALTY PAYMENTS.
TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE, TWO
EXAMPLES ONE, SAY A BORROWER
ACCUMULATES A BALANCE OF $1,000
ON A CREDIT CARD WITH A 30% APR
FOR FIVE YEARS. THE BORROWER WAS
UNABLE TO PAY OFF THE CREDIT'S
BALANCE, BUT MAKES PAYMENTS THAT
ONLY COVER THE ACCRUED INTEREST
AND THE TOTAL PAYMENTS THAT
THEY'VE MADE. TOTAL $1,500 BY
THE END OF THE FIVE YEARS. THE
CREDIT CARD COMPANY HAS EARNED
$1,500 FROM THEIR INITIAL LOAN
OF $1,000, WITH THE PRINCIPAL
STILL OUTSTANDING. THE BORROWER
THEN DECLARES BANKRUPTCY AND
DEFAULTS THE CREDIT CARD COMPANY
IS THEN ALLOWED TO CLAIM A SALES
TAX REFUND OF ABOUT $85 FROM THE
STATE, RELATED TO THE ORIGINAL
$1,000 BALANCE, DESPITE HAVING
RECOVERED THE ENTIRE PRINCIPAL
AND HAVING MADE AN ADDITIONAL
$500 ON THE LOAN. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE A BORROWER PURCHASES
$33,000 CAR USING 8% APR LOAN
ISSUED BY THE CAR MANUFACTURER,
PAYING AROUND $36,000 AFTER THE
SALES TAX IS APPLIED. THE
BORROWER DOESN'T MISS A PAYMENT
AND PAYS OFF THE ENTIRE LOAN
OVER FIVE YEARS. OVER THAT
PERIOD, THE BORROWER PAYS ABOUT
$7,000 IN INTEREST, INCLUDING
NEARLY $600 OF THAT BEING
ADDITIONAL INTEREST PAYMENTS.
ONLY FROM THE PORTION RELATED TO
THE SALES TAX. GIVEN THAT THE
LENDER IS EARNING INTEREST ON
THE PORTION OF THE LOAN RELATED
TO THE SALES TAX, IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHY THE SALES TAX PORTION OF THE
LOAN SHOULD BE SUBSIDIZED. THE
SALES TAX IS NOT DUE ONCE THE
LOAN IS PAID OFF, IT IS DUE AT
THE TIME OF PURCHASE AND THE
LOAN AMOUNT IS EQUAL TO THE
TOTAL PRICE OF THE GOOD,
INCLUDING A VARIETY OF
COMPONENTS SUCH AS SALES TAX,
VEHICLE LICENSE FEES,
REGISTRATION FEES, ETC. IT'S
UNLIKELY THE DEDUCTION AND
REFUND IMPACTS CREDIT MARKETS.
OPPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL
IMPLICITLY ASSUME THAT
SUBSIDIZING LOANS FOR THE BAD
DEBT DEDUCTION INCREASES CREDIT
AVAILABILITY AND REDUCES CREDIT
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS,
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH BAD
CREDIT OR LOW INCOME. HOWEVER,
WE HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE THAT
THE CREDIT IS MORE AVAILABLE OR
CHEAPER IN OTHER STATES THAT
OFFER THIS DEDUCTION TO LENDERS
OFFER THIS DEDUCTION TO LENDERS,
OR THAT REMOVING THIS DEDUCTION
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE CREDIT
AVAILABILITY. BAD DEBT REFUND
CLAIMS BY LENDERS TOTAL ROUGHLY
ABOUT 110 MILLION PER YEAR,
WHICH RELATES TO ROUGHLY $1.3
BILLION IN DEBT TRANSACTIONS BY
CONTRAST, THERE IS ROUGHLY $540
BILLION IN OUTSTANDING
NON-MORTGAGE CONSUMER CREDIT IN
CALIFORNIA AT ANY GIVEN TIME,
MEANING THAT THE TRANSACTIONS
AFFECTED BY THIS POLICY
CONSTITUTE A VANISHINGLY SMALL
PERCENT OF CREDIT OVERALL, AND
ONLY AROUND 0.2% OUT OF THE 45
STATES THAT CHARGE SALES TAX, 40
STATES CURRENTLY DISALLOW SALES
TAX DEDUCTIONS FOR ALL NON
RETAILER LENDERS FOR SALES TAX
PAID ON BAD DEBTS. THIS PROPOSAL
ALIGNS CALIFORNIA WITH THE 40
OTHER STATES TO CURRENTLY
DISALLOW BAD DEBT DEDUCTIONS FOR
NON RETAIL LENDERS. COST TO THE
STATE ARE LIKELY
COUNTERCYCLICAL. THE COST OF THE
EXEMPTION DEDUCTION IS
COUNTERCYCLICAL FOR THE STATE.
BECAUSE CREDIT DEFAULTS ARE
LIKELY TO RISE CONCURRENTLY WHEN
THE BUDGET WITH BUDGET
SHORTFALLS AND EXPENDITURE CUTS
DURING TIMES OF ECONOMIC
WEAKNESS, MEANING THE COST OF
THE DEDUCTION TO THE STATE
INCREASES FOR THE STATE AT TIMES
WHEN THE STATE MOST NEEDS IT TO
CONTINUE FUNDING VALUABLE STATE
PROGRAMS. ADMINISTRATION OF THE
DEDUCTION REFUND IS INCONSISTENT
WITH MOST SALES TAX DEDUCTIONS
REFUNDS LEADING TO COMPLEXITY.
THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION REFUND IS
UNUSUAL IN THAT IT IS ALLOWED TO
LENDERS, EVEN THOUGH THE SALES
TAX RELATED TO PURCHASES MADE ON
CREDIT IS PAID BY THE RETAILER,
NOT THE LENDER. ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY RESULTING FROM THIS
UNUSUAL ARRANGEMENT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT WORK FOR CDTFA,
WHICH ESTIMATES THAT PROCESSING
BAD DEBT REFUND CLAIMS TAKES
ABOUT 6000 HOURS PER YEAR FOR
THEIR FIELD AUDITORS AND
ADDITIONAL HOURS FOR OTHER AUDIT
STAFF. ENDING THE POLICY WILL
LIKELY ALLOW FOR SIGNIFICANT
TIME AND RESOURCES TO BE
REDIRECTED TO REVENUE GENERATING
AUDIT ACTIVITIES. AND FINALLY,
IT'S LIKELY NOT THE BEST WAY TO
SUBSIDIZE DEBT. IF SUBSIDIZING
DEBT WERE A POLICY GOAL, THE
DEDUCTION IS NOT WELL TARGETED
BECAUSE CLAIMS CAN BE RELATED TO
LOANS MADE TO ANY BORROWER, NOT
JUST THOSE WHO HAVE TROUBLE
OBTAINING LOANS. IT'S DIFFICULT
TO ADMINISTER DUE TO
AFOREMENTIONED ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY, AND DOES NOT ALLOW
THE STATE A HIGH LEVEL OF
CONTROL IN WHO RECEIVES THE
BENEFIT OR HOW MUCH IT COSTS THE
STATE PER YEAR. FINANCE BECAME
AWARE THAT THE CDTFA HAS PENDING
REFUND CLAIMS FOR PRIOR YEARS,
MEANING THAT ANY GIVEN TIME, A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
REFUNDS BEING ISSUED WERE
RELATED TO DEBT WRITTEN OFF IN
PRIOR YEARS. BECAUSE THE
PROPOSAL ONLY ELIMINATES THE
DEDUCTION FOR DEBT WRITTEN AFTER
JANUARY FIRST, 2025, CDTFA WILL
STILL NEED TO WORK THROUGH THESE
CLAIMS IN ADDITION TO ANY
ADDITIONAL CLAIMS RECEIVED GOING
FORWARD THAT ARE FOR PERIODS
PRIOR TO JANUARY 1ST, 2025. BUT
STILL WITHIN THE THREE YEAR
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS PUSHING A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
REVENUE GAIN OUT BY THREE YEARS,
THE PROPOSAL WOULD RAISE 50.6
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND SALES
TAX REVENUE PER YEAR ONCE THE
PENDING CLAIMS ARE PROCESSED AND
NO FURTHER CLAIMS ARE RECEIVED
DUE TO THE EXPIRATION OF THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS AS A
RESULT OF THIS BACKLOG, FINANCE
ESTIMATES IN MAY REVISION THAT
THE PROPOSAL RAISES GENERAL FUND
REVENUES OF 2.5 MILLION IN 2425,
10 MILLION EACH IN 2526 AND
2627, 30,000,000IN 2728, AND IN
50.6 MILLION ONGOING BEGINNING
NO LATER THAN 2829. ANOTHER 60
MILLION PER YEAR WOULD GO TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGH THEIR
SALES TAX RATES ONCE THE BACKLOG
IS CLEARED IN 2029, FOR THE
REASONS STATED PREVIOUSLY, THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION
FOR LENDERS AND AFFILIATES.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
ADDITIONAL REPORTING FROM LÀ.
SETH KERSTEIN, LEO, RELATIVE TO
THE ADMINISTRATION'S THOROUGH
TREATMENT OF THE ISSUES RELATED
TO THESE PROPOSAL OR THIS
PROPOSAL ARE ONLY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT IS THAT IN A YEAR FULL
OF DIFFICULT DECISIONS, A
PROPOSAL LIKE THIS WARRANTS
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION. AN
ADDITIONAL FROM DEPARTMENT. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. ARE THERE, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, YOU ADDRESSED
IT TO SOME EXTENT. THE CRITICISM
ABOUT DECREASING, ACCESSIBILITY
TO LENDING AND THE IMPACT ON
COST. DID YOU WANT TO EXPOUND ON
THAT ANY FURTHER? SURE.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
GENEROUS STATES IN THE TREATMENT
OF THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION, IT'S
ONE OF ONLY FIVE STATES THAT
ALLOWS IT FOR LENDERS AND
RETAILERS AFFILIATES. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF STATES THAT CHARGE
SALES TAX, 40 OF THE 45 DO NOT.
AND THERE'S NO EVIDENCE BETWEEN
THE STATES THAT THERE'S GREATER
CREDIT AVAILABILITY OR LOWER
INTEREST RATES, FROM STATES THAT
ALLOW IT FOR LENDERS AND
RETAILERS, AFFILIATES AND THOSE
THAT DO NOT. AND ALSO, THIS IS
SUCH A SMALL PART OF THE BROADER
CREDIT MARKETPLACE. AS I
MENTIONED, EARLIER ON, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT 1.3 BILLION OF THE
$540 BILLION IN NON-MORTGAGE
CREDIT DEBT. SO THIS IS JUST A
SMALL FRACTION, 0.2. IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON, ON
THE BROADER CREDIT MARKETPLACE.
MAJORITY OF THE BORROWERS. ALL
RIGHT. I'LL BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS? COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I KNOW WE'LL HAVE
A MINOR SUBSTITUTION. THAT ISSUE
13 WILL BE HELD OPEN. MOVES US
TO FTB IN ISSUE 14, WHICH IS NOL
AND BUSINESS TAX CREDIT
SUSPENSION. SO I THINK WE HAVE
ONE SWITCH.
ALL RIGHT. WELCOME. AND, YOUR
NAME AND TITLE FOR THE RECORD.
AND PROCEED WHEN READY, GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. NICK
THOMAS, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
SO, AS PART OF SOLVING THE
PROJECTED DEFICIT AND TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET, NOT JUST FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR, BUT ALSO FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AS WELL, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND, NET OPERATING LOSS USE
FOR MEDIUM AND LARGE BUSINESSES
AND TO LIMIT BUSINESS CREDIT
USAGE. TO $5 MILLION PER YEAR,
THE SOLUTION WOULD BE IN EFFECT
FOR TAX YEAR 2025, 2026 AND
2027. BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN
$1 MILLION IN TAXABLE INCOME
WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM THE NOL
SUSPENSION, AND ALL BUSINESSES
WOULD BE ABLE TO USE THEIR
CREDITS UP TO $5 MILLION PER
YEAR, THEREFORE, SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD GENERALLY NOT
BE IMPACTED BY THIS PROPOSAL.
THE SOLUTION IS SUBJECT TO A
TRIGGER, WHEREBY IF CASH
RECEIPTS THROUGH APRIL 2025,
COME IN ABOVE EXPECTATIONS SUCH
THAT THE SOLUTION IS NO LONGER
NEEDED, SUCH THAT THE SOLUTION
IS NO LONGER NEEDED. THE
SUSPENSION AND CREDIT LIMITATION
WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT, THE
TEMPORARY NOL SUSPENSION AND
CREDIT LIMITATION REPLACES THE
ONGOING 80% NOL LIMITATION THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THIS ANIMAL SUSPENSION
AND CREDIT LIMITATION LARGELY
MIRRORS THE SUSPENSION AND
LIMITATION FROM 2020 AND 2021.
INCLUDING THE PROTECTION FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE TWO KEY DIFFERENCES, FIRST,
IT HAS A MUCH LONGER LEAD TIME
TO ALLOW BUSINESSES TO BETTER
PLAN AHEAD SO IT WOULDN'T TAKE
EFFECT IN THE CURRENT TAX YEAR,
AND THEN SECOND, IT INCLUDES THE
AFOREMENTIONED CASH TRIGGER. THE
STATE HAS HISTORICALLY UTILIZED
NOL SUSPENSION TO HELP BALANCE
THE BUDGET DURING REVENUE
DOWNTURNS, THIS INCLUDES DURING
THE EARLY 1990S, IN THE EARLY
2000, FOLLOWING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND THEN MOST RECENTLY
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
ADDITIONALLY, IT PUT IN PLACE
CREDIT LIMITATIONS AS PART OF
THE LATTER TWO, SO AS PART OF
THIS PROPOSAL, THE CARRY
FORWARDS FOR BUSINESSES TO USE
THEIR NOLS AND CREDITS WILL BE
EXTENDED BY THREE YEARS, AND
THEREFORE THOSE CREDITS AND
ANIMALS ARE EXPECTED TO BE USED
IN THE LONG TERM AND GENERALLY
IT'S, AND SO YEAH, OVERALL THERE
WOULD NOT BE A, AN IMPACT IN THE
TOTAL USE OF NOLS OR CREDITS,
THE PROPOSAL IS ESTIMATED TO
GENERATE $900 MILLION IN THE
BUDGET WINDOW AND ALSO INCREASED
REVENUES THROUGH THE MULTI YEAR,
INCLUDING BY $5.5 BILLION IN
2526. HOWEVER, IT WOULD RESULT
IN REVENUE LOSSES AFTER THE
MULTI YEAR AS COMPANIES ARE ABLE
TO FULLY UTILIZE THEIR NOLS AND
CREDITS, INCLUDING ANY BACKLOGS
DURING THE YEARS OF THE
SUSPENSION AND LIMITATION, OF
NOTE, THESE REVENUE ESTIMATES
ARE ACHIEVED IN PART BECAUSE
THERE IS A LIMITATION ON BOTH
NOLS AND CREDITS BECAUSE MANY
COMPANIES HAVE A STOCK OF BOTH
NOLS AND CREDITS ENACTING A
LIMITATION ON JUST NOLS OR JUST
CREDITS WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE REVENUE GAINS FROM THE
SOLUTION. AS MANY COMPANIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO AVOID THE
IMPACTS BY MERELY SHIFTING THEIR
USE FROM EITHER NOLS OR CREDITS.
WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT,
REPORTING FROM THE LAO OR THE
BOARD? YES. THANK YOU. BRIAN
UHLER FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, SO WE HAVE
COMMENTS ON BOTH PIECES, THE
NULL DEDUCTIONS AND THE CREDITS,
AND SO LET ME START BY ACTUALLY
ADDRESSING THE LAST POINT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
SORT OF THE INTERACTION BETWEEN
THESE TWO POLICIES, SINCE WE'RE
SORT OF SUGGESTING TO BIFURCATE
THEM, WE DO WE DEFINITELY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS AN
INTERACTION WHERE YOU DO ACHIEVE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE GAINS BY
ADOPTING THEM TOGETHER. THAT
BEING SAID, IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING FROM PAST
ESTIMATES OF WHEN THESE POLICIES
WERE PUT IN PLACE THAT, THE
MAJORITY, YOU WOULD STILL
MAINTAIN THE MAJORITY OF THE
REVENUE THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT TO
GET FROM DOING ONE, ONE OR THE
OTHER. IT WOULD ONLY BE A
MINORITY OF THE REVENUE GAINS
ASSOCIATED WITH EITHER ITEM THAT
YOU WOULD BE LOSING BY NOT
ADDING THE, THE OTHER COMPONENT,
SO TURNING INTO FIRST TO THE TAX
CREDIT COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSAL
, IT IS OUR POSITION THAT THE
BUSINESS TAX CREDITS CAN AND
SHOULD BE EVALUATED AS SPENDING
PROGRAMS. THEY'RE ESSENTIALLY A
SPENDING THAT IS EFFECTUATED
THROUGH THE STATE'S TAX SYSTEM.
AND FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE, YOU
KNOW, WE THINK IT'S SOMEWHAT
DIFFICULT TO JUSTIFY MAINTAINING
THOSE CREDITS IN FULL IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE IS CONSIDERING
MAKING SIGNIFICANT SPENDING
REDUCTIONS IN MANY OTHER AREAS
OF THE BUDGET, YOU KNOW,
NOTWITHSTANDING THAT THE, THE
THESE TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS ARE
AIMING TO ACHIEVE MANY
WORTHWHILE GOALS, THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THOSE GOALS REALLY ARE SORT OF
CORE STATE RESPONSIBILITIES OR
CRITICAL NEEDS AT THIS TIME, AND
, AND FOR THAT REASON, WE THINK
THAT THE CREDIT PORTION OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS WORTH SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION ON THE NULL
DEDUCTIONS PORTION, THE NULL
DEDUCTIONS ARE ARE SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT THAN THE TAX CREDITS.
AND THAT WHERE TAX CREDITS ARE
SORT OF SOMETHING THAT ARE KIND
OF ADDED ON TO THE STATE'S TAX
SYSTEM ATTEMPTING TO ACHIEVE A
SORT OF A SECONDARY POLICY GOAL.
NOLS ARE ACTUALLY SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE FUNDAMENTAL TO THE
WAY THAT CALIFORNIA SORT OF
DEFINES INCOME FOR THE PURPOSE
OF TAXATION. AND THE PURPOSE OF
NOLS IS TO ALLOW TAXPAYERS TO
SMOOTH THEIR PROFITS AND LOSSES
OVER TIME, SO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE A BUSINESS THAT EARNS THE
SAME AMOUNT OF INCOME OVER TIME
AS ANOTHER BUSINESS, BUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN A MORE CYCLICAL
BUSINESS, OR THEY UNDERTAKE MORE
RISKY OR INNOVATIVE, BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES, AND THEIR INCOME
FLUCTUATES MORE OVER TIME,
WITHOUT THE NOLS, THAT BUSINESS
THAT IS IN THAT MORE RISKY OR
CYCLICAL BUSINESS ACTIVITY WILL
BE PAYING MORE TAXES THAN ONE
THAT EARNS SIMILAR INCOME. BUT
DOES IT MORE STEADILY, AND FOR
THAT REASON, NOLS ARE SORT OF A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE TAX
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE FOR MORE EVEN
TREATMENT OF THOSE TWO TYPES OF
BUSINESSES, SO WHILE NULL
DEDUCTIONS HAVE BEEN A SORT OF A
GO TO BUDGET SOLUTION FOR THE
STATE IN THE PAST, THE FREQUENCY
AT WHICH THE STATE IS NOW USING
THIS POLICY IS STARTING TO RAISE
STARTING TO RAISE A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
UNDERMINING THE FUNDAMENTAL
REASON FOR HAVING NULL
DEDUCTIONS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF THIS PROPOSAL TAKES EFFECT,
AS PROPOSED, THE STATE WILL HAVE
SUSPENDED NOLS FOR NEARLY HALF
OF YEARS. OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES, AND SO THAT FOR THAT,
FOR THAT REASON, THAT PART OF
THE PROPOSAL RAISES CONCERNS FOR
US. AND WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT IF
THE LEGISLATURE IS IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THE GOVERNOR IN SEEKING
THIS MAGNITUDE OF REVENUE
SOLUTIONS, THAT YOU CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO RAISE
REVENUE, WHICH I THINK WILL
ADDRESS ON THE NEXT ITEM. SO
FURTHER. ALL RIGHT, AS TO THE
TRIGGERING PROCESS INTERNALLY,
CAN YOU GIVE US A LITTLE LIGHT
ON WHAT THAT PROCESS LOOKS LIKE
INTERNALLY? YEAH. SO THE TRIGGER
MECHANISM WOULD LOOK AT CASH
RECEIPTS BETWEEN MAY OF THIS
YEAR. SO THE CURRENT MONTH WE'RE
IN THROUGH APRIL OF 2025, AND
THE TRIGGER WOULD SO ESSENTIALLY
THE SUSPENSION AND LIMITATION
WOULD GET TURNED OFF IF CASH
RECEIPTS EXCEEDED PROJECTIONS
FROM THIS BUDGET BY 3% OR MORE.
AND THAT ESSENTIALLY ALIGNS WITH
THE EXPECTED SHORT TERM REVENUE
INCREASE OF THE, OF THE PROPOSAL
IN THE MAY REVISION. AND SO THAT
WOULD BE THAT WOULD LOOK AT CASH
RECEIPTS THROUGH THE END OF
APRIL OF NEXT YEAR, WHICH WOULD
BE KNOWN IN EARLY MAY. I'LL
BRING IT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE,
SENATOR NEIL, A QUESTION ABOUT
CREDITS. I WOULD ASSUME THAT
ONCE THE LIMIT OF 5 MILLION OF
THE CREDIT IS MET, ANY EXPENSES
OVER AND ABOVE THAT WOULD STILL
BE DEDUCTIBLE FROM INCOME FOR
TAX PURPOSES AS AN ORDINARY AND
NECESSARY EXPENSE. COLBY WHITE,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES,
ABSOLUTELY. THE CREDITS CREDITS
ARE ONE FOR ONE OFFSET AGAINST
YOUR LIABILITY, AND THEY'RE
CALCULATED AFTER, YOU KNOW, YOU
HAVE YOUR TAXABLE INCOME AND
THEN YOU HAVE YOUR, SORRY, YOU
HAVE YOUR GROSS INCOME, THEN YOU
HAVE DEDUCTIONS, WHICH IS WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING THOSE AREN'T NONE
OF THOSE ARE BEING CHANGED. AND
THEN THAT LEADS TO YOUR TAXABLE
INCOME. YOU MULTIPLY BY A TAX
RATE AND YOU HAVE YOUR LIABILITY
THAT THAT'S WHEN CREDITS ARE
APPLIED. CREDITS ARE ONE FOR ONE
REDUCTION AGAINST LIABILITY. SO
NOTHING IN THIS PROPOSAL AFFECTS
AFFECTS TAX DEDUCTIONS. THE
COMPANIES CAN TAKE. OKAY. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WITH REGARD
TO THE, NET OPERATING LOSS CARRY
FORWARD. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THE PRACTICAL, EFFECT,
OR OR REASON FOR THAT. WHEN A
BUSINESS LOSES MONEY, THEIR
RESOURCES ARE COMPROMISED AND A
REASON TO ALLOW FOR A QUICK
RECOVERY OF THAT ONCE PROFITABLE
RETURNS IS TO RESTORE CAPITAL.
AND IF LOSSES ARE SERIOUS ENOUGH
, REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OF
BUSINESS. AND ONCE THEY START
MAKING MONEY AND AREN'T ABLE TO
OFFSET THAT THOSE PROFITS WITH
THE PAST LOSSES, IT COULD PUT
THE BUSINESS IN A SERIOUS,
POSITION RELATIVE TO RESTORING
THEIR CAPITAL AFTER A PERIOD OF
HAVING BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
COMPROMISED. AND SO IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE REASONS THAT THE LAW STATES
THAT, THAT MOVE WOULD NOT BE
GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY OF THE
STATE, GIVEN THAT INDIVIDUAL
BUSINESSES COULD POTENTIALLY
SUFFER SIGNIFICANTLY HAVING TO
WAIT FOR THAT RECOVER OF THE, OF
THE LOSS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
THAT I DON'T BE HELD OPEN, AND
WE'LL MOVE TO THE NEXT ISSUE,
WHICH IS AN ITEM ON ALTERNATIVE
REVENUE OPTIONS. LEO SO AS THE
CHAIR MENTIONED THIS, THIS ITEM
IS TO CONSIDER A NUMBER OF
ALTERNATIVE, REVENUE OPTIONS.
AND I'LL START BY DISCUSSING
SOME OPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
FORWARD BY OUR OFFICE AND SOME
OF OUR RECENT PUBLICATIONS,
STARTING WITH OUR SUGGESTION
THAT A PLACE TO START WOULD BE
TO LOOK AT REEVALUATING SOME TAX
EXPENDITURES, AND SO TO START
WITH, THERE'S, THERE'S FOUR THAT
WE'VE LISTED. THE FIRST ONE IS
ELIMINATING THE CAPITAL GAINS.
STEP UP BASIS. AND THIS HAS TO
DO WITH ESSENTIALLY THE TAX
BASIS FOR AN ASSET WHEN IT IS
INHERITED. SO, LET ME SORT OF
GIVE AN EXAMPLE. IF A IF A
PARENT BUYS A STOCK FOR $20, IT
THEN GOES UP IN VALUE TO $50,
AND THEN THAT STOCK IS PASSED ON
TO THE CHILD. AND, WHEN THE
CHILD THEN INHERITS THE STOCK,
IT GOES UP TO $60. WHEN THE
CHILD FINALLY SELLS IT 60, THE
CAPITAL GAINS STEP UP BASIS SAYS
, THAT THEY'RE ONLY TAXED FOR
THEIR CAPITAL GAIN ON THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN 50 AND 60
INSTEAD OF THE ORIGINAL $20 THAT
THE PARENT, PAID FOR IT, THE
ORIGINAL REASON FOR THE STEP UP
BASIS WAS PRIMARILY TO AVOID
DOUBLE TAXATION IN THE PRESENCE
OF A STATE TAXES, WHICH THE
STATE HAS NOT HAD FOR MANY
YEARS. AND FOR THAT REASON, WE
THINK THAT, RECONSIDERING THE
CAPITAL GAINS STEP UP BASIS
COULD BE WORTHWHILE, THE SECOND
SORT OF TAX EXPENDITURE THAT WE
WOULD SUGGEST LOOKING AT IS THE
MORTGAGE INTEREST DEDUCTION,
WHICH WHICH WE WOULD SUGGEST IS
SORT OF POORLY TARGETED FOR
ACHIEVING ITS OBJECTIVE OF
PROMOTING HOMEOWNERSHIP, AND
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
BENEFITS FROM THE DEDUCTION GO
TO HIGHER INCOME TAXPAYERS,
BECAUSE IT IS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE WHO ARE
ITEMIZE THEIR TAXES, WHICH IS A
SMALL SUBSET OF, OF TAXPAYERS
THAT THAT TENDS TO BE HIGHER
INCOME. SO ONE OPTION FOR BETTER
TARGETING THE MORTGAGE INTEREST
DEDUCTION COULD BE TO CONVERT IT
INTO A CREDIT, WHICH WOULD MAKE
IT AVAILABLE TO A LARGER, RANGE
OF, OF INCOME OF TAXPAYERS, AND
THAT COULD BE THAT CREDIT COULD
BE DESIGNED IN A WAY THAT IT
COULD ALSO SIMULTANEOUSLY
GENERATE SOME REVENUE GAINS FOR
THE STATE, THERE'S AN EXAMPLE IN
YOUR AGENDA THAT IF YOU SET THE
CREDIT EQUAL TO 2% OF MORTGAGE
INTEREST PAID BY TAXPAYERS, THAT
THE STATE WOULD LIKELY, RECEIVE
REVENUE GAINS OF A BILLION OR
MORE PER YEAR, A SECOND MORTGAGE
INTEREST DEDUCTION OPTION WOULD
BE TO RECONSIDER THE ALLOWANCE
OF MORTGAGE INTEREST DEDUCTIONS
FOR SECOND HOMES, THE FINAL TAX
EXPENDITURE THAT WE WOULD
MENTION IS THE EXEMPTION FROM
THE FIRST YEAR MINIMUM FRANCHISE
TAX FOR CORPORATIONS. AND SO
ESSENTIALLY ALL BUSINESSES, EVEN
IF THEY HAVE NO, TAX LIABILITY
AT ALL, ARE REQUIRED TO PAY $800
EVERY YEAR, ESSENTIALLY FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND RECEIVING THE
LEGAL PROTECTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH BEING AN INCORPORATED
BUSINESS ENTITY, WE THINK THAT
THIS TAX EXPENDITURE IS A POORLY
TARGETED WAY OF ACHIEVING ITS
OBJECTIVE OF PROMOTING A SMALL
BUSINESS FORMATION AND THEREFORE
SUGGEST A REVISITING THAT, IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE NOLAN CREDIT
SUSPENSION PROPOSAL, WE ALSO WE
SUGGESTED THAT, EXPLORING
POTENTIALLY A TEMPORARY,
CORPORATION TAX RATE INCREASE
IN, IN PLACE OF DOING THE NULL
SUSPENSION ALSO COULD BE AN
OPTION, AND OUR SORT OF
PRELIMINARY ESTIMATE IS THAT A
RATE INCREASE OF 1.5% WOULD
LIKELY YIELD, WOULD WOULD
REPLACE THE REVENUE THAT YOU
WOULD ACHIEVE BY ADOPTING THE
NULL SUSPENSION IN COMBINATION
WITH THE CREDITS, AND, YOU KNOW,
A CONSIDERATION THERE COULD BE
IT COULD BE A TEMPORARY INCREASE
FOLLOWED BY A TEMPORARY RATE
DEDUCTION IN FUTURE YEARS. AND
THAT COULD, YOU KNOW, SORT OF
MIRROR SOME OF THE BENEFIT THAT
YOU GET WITH THE NULL
SUSPENSIONS AND THAT A TAXPAYERS
PAY MORE TAXES UP FRONT AND THEN
USE THOSE NULLS LATER TO REDUCE
THEIR TAXES IN OUT YEARS. A
FINAL ITEM IS, HAS TO DO WITH
THE SINGLE SALES FACTOR FOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. AND SO
THE BASIC IDEA HERE IS THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE A BUSINESS THAT EARNS
INCOME IN MULTIPLE STATES,
STATES HAVE TO COME UP WITH SOME
WAY OF DIVIDING THE INCOME FOR
TAX PURPOSES TO AVOID DOUBLE
TAXATION, FOR MOST BUSINESSES,
CALIFORNIA SAYS THAT, THAT THEIR
INCOME IS DIVIDED BASED ON WHERE
THEIR SALES OCCUR FOR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS, THERE'S THREE
FACTORS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
SALES THE AMOUNT OF THEIR
PROPERTY AND THE AMOUNT OF THEIR
PAYROLL, AND SO THIS ITEM WOULD
BE TO CONSIDER ALIGNING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WITH THE
TAX TREATMENT THAT APPLIES TO
MOST OTHER BUSINESSES, AND FTTB
IS ESTIMATED THAT COULD RAISE,
$260 MILLION IN 2425. COMMENTS
COLBY WHITE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WE DON'T I DON'T HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS. AS THE
GOVERNOR MADE CLEAR, THE MAY
REVISION IS THE PROPOSAL IS A
FIRST PART OF THE PROCESS, AND
WE'RE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY CONSIDER
ALTERNATIVES, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMING WEEKS.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO, SINGLE
SALES FACTOR FOR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND JUST KIND OF
WALK FOLKS WHO NEVER HEARD THAT
TERM BEFORE, WHO MAY NOT HAVE
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE FOR
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS BENDING
ON THE ASSETS THEY HAVE AND
WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED, WHERE THE
WORK FORCE AND PAYROLL ARE
LOCATED IN OR OUT OF CALIFORNIA,
IT PAINT A PICTURE FOR US.
RIGHT? SO I THINK SO THE IN
THINKING ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA USED TO HAVE THE
THREE FACTOR SYSTEM APPLY TO ALL
BUSINESSES AND THERE WAS A SHIFT
TO SINGLE SALES FACTOR TO, TO
MOST BUSINESSES UNDER THE SORT
OF THE JUSTIFICATION THERE IS
THAT IN SOME SENSE, YOUR, YOUR
BY, BY APPLYING THE
APPORTIONMENT BASED ON THE
LOCATION OF PROPERTY AND
PAYROLL, YOU'RE IN SOME SENSE
SORT OF PENALIZING BUSINESSES
FOR LOCATING THEIR OFFICES AND
JOBS IN THE STATE. AND SO THE
CONCEPT IS THAT BY DOING THE
APPORTIONMENT BASED ON SALES,
SPECIFICALLY, THAT YOU MIGHT
GIVE AN INCENTIVE FOR BUSINESSES
TO LOCATE MORE OF THEIR OFFICES
AND JOBS HERE AND DO MORE OF
THEIR SALES OUT OF THE STATE,
THERE IS, YOU KNOW, MAYBE A ONE
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF
CONSIDERATION WITH FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS IS, THE, THE
PRODUCT THAT THEY'RE SELLING IN
THIS CASE, YOU KNOW, WITH WHEN
YOU INCREASE THE, THE AMOUNT OF
WEIGHT THAT IS PLACED ON SALES
FOR APPORTIONMENT, YOU MIGHT
SOMEWHAT REDUCE THE, YOU KNOW,
THEIR INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO DO
SALES INTO THE STATE AND FOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WHERE,
YOU KNOW, PRIMARILY TALKING
ABOUT LOANS TO, TO BUSINESSES
AND PROPERTY HOLDERS. SO YOU
COULD, YOU KNOW, TO SOME DEGREE,
CREATE SOME REDUCE INCENTIVE FOR
PROVIDING THOSE LOANS. SO ON THE
ONE HAND, YOU KNOW, PERHAPS
INCREASE INCENTIVE TO LOCATE
THEIR JOBS AND OFFICES HERE ON
THE OTHER HAND, MAYBE SOME
REDUCED LOAN ACTIVITY. TO THE
SUB, SENATOR NILO, BACK TO THE
SINGLE SALES FACTOR THAT, THE
CHOICE THAT WAS ADDED TO THAT
CALCULATION WAS AN OUTGROWTH OF
THE 2009, BUDGET SETTLEMENT,
FROM MY STANDPOINT, HAVING BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THAT, THE CHOICE
WAS NOT WHAT I HAD IN MIND, AND
IT WAS TO JUST HAVE THE SINGLE
SALES FACTOR SO THAT A BUSINESS
WAS NOT PUNISHED, IF YOU WILL,
FOR HAVING A HEAVY PROPORTION OF
, PAYROLL AND PROPERTY IN, IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WHAT IS THIS
CHANGE THAT YOU'RE RECOMMENDING,
I'M NOT SURE THAT I FULLY
UNDERSTAND. IS IT TO NOT ALLOW
THE CHOICE TO HAVE IT BE JUST
SINGLE SALES FACTOR FOR EVERY
COMPANY? NO. SO. SORRY. IT'S,
IT'S MUCH NARROWER. AND I GUESS
I SHOULD ACTUALLY ALSO CLARIFY.
WE'RE JUST, ON THIS ITEM, OR I'M
JUST SORT OF DESCRIBING AN
OPTION THAT HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD
TO THE COMMITTEE. IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A FORMAL
RECOMMENDATION OF OUR OFFICE,
THAT BEING SAID, THIS OPTION IS
MORE NARROW THAN, THAN, MAYBE MY
INITIAL DESCRIPTION MAY HAVE LED
ON. SO THIS APPLIES ONLY TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. OH. JUST
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION, FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. WHEREAS THE
MAJORITY OF BUSINESSES ARE ON
ARE SINGLE SALES FACTOR. THERE
ARE A LIMITED NUMBER OF SECTORS,
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS BEING ONE
THAT ARE STILL ON THE OLD THREE
FACTOR SYSTEM. THIS WOULD MOVE
JUST FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO
SINGLE SALES FACTOR. SO THAT
CHOICE HAS EVOLVED SINCE 2009
BECAUSE INITIALLY IT WAS A
CHOICE FOR EVERY CORPORATION.
THAT'S RIGHT. SO THERE WAS,
AFTER 2009, THERE WAS A, THERE
WAS A BALLOT MEASURE WHICH.
THAT'S RIGHT, REMOVED THE CHOICE
AND MADE SINGLE SALES FACTOR
MANDATORY FOR ALL BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU FOR REFRESHING MY
MEMORY. THAT DISAPPEARED WHEN I
WAS TERMED OUT BEFORE. THANKS.
THANK YOU. SENATOR AND, SENATOR
SMALL CHÁVEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I JUST HAD A CLARIFYING
QUESTION ON THE CAPITAL GAINS
STEP, STEP UP BASIS. IS THERE
LIKE A ASSET THRESHOLD FOR THIS?
IS IT FOR EVERY LEVEL OF
INHERITANCE? IS IT OVER A
CERTAIN AMOUNT? I THINK I MEAN
THERE'S SO THERE CERTAINLY COULD
BE SOME SOME MERIT TO
CONSIDERING SORT OF AN ASSET
THRESHOLD. AND ONE OF, YOU KNOW,
I MENTIONED THE PRIMARY
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE POLICY
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN TO AVOID
DOUBLE TAXATION WITH THE STATE
TAXES. ANOTHER POTENTIAL
ARGUMENT MIGHT BE THAT, IT, YOU
KNOW, IT PROVIDES SOME EASE OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR TAXPAYERS. IT
MAY BE THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
PARENT BOUGHT THE ASSET A LONG
TIME AGO. THEY MAY NOT HAVE KEPT
THE PROPER PAPERWORK TO ALLOW
THE CHILDREN TO FILE THE TAXES
APPROPRIATELY WITHOUT STEP UP
BASIS, AND SO APPLYING SOME YOU
KNOW, SORT OF ASSET LEVEL SO
THAT THIS DOESN'T APPLY TO, YOU
KNOW, MAYBE SOME MORE MIDDLE
INCOME, YOU KNOW, TAXPAYERS WHO
MIGHT NOT HAVE KEPT THAT
PAPERWORK, MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
ACCOUNTANT, YOU KNOW, EXPERTISE
TO ALLOW THEM TO NAVIGATE THAT
THAT COULD BE WORTH CONSIDERING
AND LIKELY WOULDN'T DIMINISH
SIGNIFICANTLY THE REVENUE
ESTIMATES THAT ARE HERE, BECAUSE
MOST OF THE REVENUE GAINS ARE
COMING FROM FOLKS WHO ARE HIGHER
UP IN THE INCOME. ALL RIGHT.
THIS ITEM WAS INFORMATION ONLY.
SO WE'LL MOVE TO THE NEXT ISSUE,
THAT'S ISSUE 16 ON CHARITABLE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS,
CONFORMITY. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ROBIN FINNESTAD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UNDER
CURRENT FEDERAL AND STATE LAW,
PROPERTY OWNERS WHO ELECT TO
GIVE UP RIGHTS TO DEVELOP
CERTAIN LAND ARE ALLOWED A
CHARITABLE DEDUCTION EQUAL TO
THE PROPERTY'S FORGONE LAND
VALUE FROM THE USE RESTRICTION.
HOWEVER, THE DEDUCTION HAS
PROVEN EASY TO ABUSE, AS
INFLATED PROPERTY APPRAISALS
HAVE ALLOWED INVESTORS THROUGH
SYNDICATED PARTNERSHIPS TO GET
IMPROPERLY LARGE TAX DEDUCTIONS.
THE FEDERAL CONSOLIDATION
APPROPRIATIONS ACT OF 2023
ADDRESSED THESE ABUSES BY DOING
THE FOLLOWING. IT LIMITED THE
DEDUCTION FOR OWNERS OF PASS
THROUGH ENTITIES TO TWO AND A
HALF TIMES THE VALUE OF THE
TAXPAYER'S INVESTMENT, AND
DISALLOWED THE DEDUCTIONS FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO HAD PREVIOUSLY
ENGAGED IN FRAUD. FOR EXAMPLE, A
PARTIAL OWNER WHO INVESTED $100
IS NOW LIMITED TO CLAIMING A
DEDUCTION OF UP TO $250.
CALIFORNIA LAW CONFORMS WITH
FEDERAL LAW IN ALLOWING
DEDUCTIONS FOR CHARITABLE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS. HOWEVER,
THE STATE HAS NOT CONFORMED TO
THE 2023 CHANGES. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CONFORM CALIFORNIA'S
TREATMENT OF THE CHARITABLE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS DEDUCTION
WITH FEDERAL LAW. BY ADOPTING
THESE CHANGES MADE IN THE CAA
BEGINNING IN TAX YEAR 2024,
CONFORMING CALIFORNIA LAW TO
FEDERAL LAW IN LIMITING THE SIZE
OF CHARITABLE CONSERVATION
EASEMENT DEDUCTIONS WILL
INCREASE ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCY AND ENSURE THAT THE
STATE IS ALIGNED WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN LIMITING
IMPROPERLY LARGE TAX DEDUCTIONS
FROM ABUSIVE TRANSACTIONS. THIS
PROPOSAL IS ESTIMATED TO
INCREASE REVENUES BY 70,000,000
IN 24, 25, $34 MILLION IN 25,
26, $25 MILLION IN 2627, AND $21
MILLION ONGOING. AND THANK YOU.
I CAN ASK I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THIS ITEM. JUST FOR
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE. AND THIS
IS A PERMANENT CHANGE, NOT A
TEMPORARY CHANGE. THAT'S CORRECT
. YES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE 17, WHICH
IS OIL AND GAS SUBSIDY
INFORMATION. THAT ITEM WILL BE
HELD. AND THE LAW IS GOING TO
TAKE THIS WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
ON THE SUMMARY OKAY. I THINK I
THINK YEAH. WHO'S GOING TO TAKE
THIS. WE'LL TAKE IT, JT CREEDON
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
ELIMINATING ALL DIRECT TAX
SUBSIDIES THAT ARE SPECIFIC AND
GIVE PREFERENCE TO THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY, BUT ARE NOT
AVAILABLE TO ALL SMALL AND LARGE
BUSINESSES IN ALL OTHER
INDUSTRIES. THESE INCLUDE
REPEALING THE INTANGIBLE
DRILLING COST DEDUCTION, THE
INCREASED PERCENTAGE MINERAL
DEPLETION ALLOWANCE, AND OIL
RECOVERY COST CREDIT. COMBINED
ELIMINATING THESE SUBSIDIES
WOULD SAVE $22 MILLION IN BUDGET
YEAR AND ROUGHLY $73 MILLION
CUMULATIVELY THROUGH 20 2728.
THESE DIRECT SUBSIDIES WERE
CREATED MANY DECADES AGO TO
INCENTIVIZE DOMESTIC OIL
PRODUCTION AND ARE NO LONGER
NECESSARY OR CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S CLIMATE AND ENERGY
GOALS. WHILE THESE SPECIAL TAX
SUBSIDIES ARE PROPOSED TO BE
ELIMINATED, OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRIES CAN CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM ALL OTHER GENERAL
BUSINESS TAX INCENTIVES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL THEIR
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE. I'LL
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS, WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THIS ITEM AS WELL,
PRIMARILY, WE AGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION THAT
THIS, THESE POLICIES ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S,
CURRENT, GOALS ON ON CLIMATE.
AND ALSO, I WOULD NOTE THAT,
ELIMINATING THESE PROVISIONS
WOULD LEAD TO MORE CONSISTENT
TAX TREATMENT, BOTH WITHIN THESE
SECTORS AND ACROSS THESE SECTORS
AND OTHER SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY
. ALL RIGHT. BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS? SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS, YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS
IS THE ONLY INDUSTRY THAT
BENEFITS FROM THESE KINDS OF,
SUBSIDIES. CAN YOU CAN YOU SHARE
WHY THAT IS? WELL, EACH OF THESE
WERE MADE FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES
, BUT MOSTLY TO SHORE UP AND
PROTECT AND ENCOURAGE DOMESTIC
OIL AND GAS DRILLING OF CRITICAL
MINERALS, SOME OF THESE ARE
ACTUAL, ACTUALLY ORIGINATED AS A
PART OF THE WORLD WAR ONE AND
WORLD WAR TWO EFFORT TO PROTECT
CRITICAL MINERALS. SO THESE AT
THE TIME, THEY JUST THIS IT WAS
CRITICAL TO THE WAR EFFORT AND
THEY WANTED TO PRESERVE THEM.
AND ALSO EARLY ON, SOME OF THE
OTHER ONES UNRELATED TO THAT
DRILLING, WAS WAS A VERY RISKY
BUSINESS, A HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
RIGHT. THERE WAS A MUCH HIGHER
RISK OF THERE BEING A DRY WELL
OR YOU PUTTING UP A LOT OF,
UPFRONT MONEY AND NOT AND BEING
STANDING TO LOSE A LOT OF
INVESTMENT THAT'S COMPLETELY
FLIPPED THESE DAYS. THE
TECHNOLOGY HAS COME A LOT SO FAR
THAT, THAT RISK ISN'T QUITE
THERE ANYMORE. ONE OTHER FOLLOW
UP QUESTION I HAVE, HOW DO YOU
LET'S SAY THIS, THIS GETS
IMPLEMENTED. HOW DO YOU PREVENT
THESE DOLLARS IN THIS GAP FROM
BEING PASSED ON TO THE CONSUMER?
IN OTHER WORDS, IF THE INDUSTRY
DOESN'T, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE TOTAL IS OF THIS
PACKAGE IS A 17 MILLION. I'M NOT
SURE. IS THERE IS THERE A WAY TO
PREVENT THE, THE INDUSTRY FROM
THEN TURNING THIS INTO AN
ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW, INCREASE IN
PRICES AT THE PUMP TO, TO FILL
THIS GAP? IS THERE A WAY TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING?
SURE WELL, FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN,
WE DON'T EXPECT THERE TO BE A
VERY BIG IMPACT IN TERMS OF, GAS
PRICES AND ENERGY PRICES
DIRECTLY, BECAUSE THIS IS A THIS
IS A VERY SMALL AMOUNT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, MOST
RETAILERS CAN'T ACTUALLY TAKE
THESE BENEFITS. SO THERE'S,
THERE'S A COUPLE STEPS REMOVED
AND, THIS IS, AGAIN, IT'S JUST A
PRETTY, PRETTY SMALL AMOUNT IN
THE GRAND SCHEME OF THE, THE OIL
AND GAS MARKET THAT WE DON'T
REALLY SEE THAT BEING AN IMPACT.
FURTHERMORE, WE'RE NOT
ELIMINATING ALL SUBSIDIES HERE.
RIGHT? SOMEBODY WHO TAKES THE,
MINERAL DEPLETION, PERCENTAGE
DEPLETION, THEY CAN STILL TAKE
COST DEPLETION. THEY CAN STILL
TAKE OTHER BUSINESS CREDITS FOR
THESE EXPENSES. SO THAT'S WHY
THE COST IS SO MARGINAL. AND WE
DON'T EXPECT THERE TO BE A HUGE
IMPACT, TO CONSUMERS IN THE
AGGREGATE. ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS THAT WILL BE HELD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MR. ISSUE 18, WHICH IS AN
INFORMATION ITEM ON
IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE ON THE
EITC.
I PANELISTS HERE. FOR THE RECORD
AND PROCEED ONE. READY SCOOCH UP
HERE. THERE WE GO. SORRY, I'M
MANDY N N, AND I'M THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY
WITH UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING. I GUESS IT'S
AFTERNOON NOW. MY NAME IS SUSAN
MAPLES, AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE ECONOMIC AND STATISTICAL
RESEARCH BUREAU AT FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. GOOD AFTERNOON. JINNEY
HARRIMAN, CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER AT FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
SURE SO I THINK I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED AGAIN. MY
NAME IS SUSAN MAPLES, AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE ECONOMIC AND
STATISTICAL RESEARCH BUREAU AT
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TODAY I'D
LIKE TO SHARE SOME STATS ON THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT, ALSO KNOWN AS CAL EITC,
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA'S OTHER
ANTI-POVERTY TAX CREDITS, THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT, WHICH
I'LL ALSO REFERRED TO AS THE
CTC, AND THE FOSTER YOUTH TAX
CREDIT. AS YOU MAY REMEMBER, THE
CAL EITC BEGAN WITH TAX YEAR
2015, AND OVER THE LAST NINE
YEARS HAS HAD MULTIPLE
EXPANSIONS IN QUALIFICATIONS,
ALLOWING MORE CALIFORNIANS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE VALUABLE
CREDITS. FOR EXAMPLE, IN 2017,
THE PROGRAM RAISED INCOME LIMITS
TO QUALIFY AND ALSO ALLOWED
CALIFORNIANS WITH ONLY
SELF-EMPLOYMENT INCOME TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE. IN 2018, THE CREDIT
WAS EXPANDED TO ALLOW CHILDLESS
TAXPAYERS TO QUALIFY AS WELL AS
ADDING ADDITIONAL AGE GROUPS
SUCH AS THOSE OVER THE AGE OF
65. IN 2019, INCOME LEVELS WERE
ONCE AGAIN EXPANDED AS
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED A YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT FOR TAXPAYERS WHO HAD
A CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF SIX
YEARS OLD. IN 2020, THE CAL EITC
WAS EXPANDED TO ALLOW THOSE
WITHOUT SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS,
BUT WHO DID HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
INCOME OR A TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER OR AN ITIN TO QUALIFY. IN
2022, BOTH CAL EITC AND THE EITC
WERE INDEXED FOR INFLATION,
LEADING TO LARGER CREDIT
AMOUNTS, AND THE EITC WAS
EXPANDED TO THOSE PARENTS WITH
NO EARNED INCOME. IN 2022. WE
ALSO SAW THE CREATION OF THE
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT TO
PROVIDE $1,000 CREDIT TO YOUNG
ADULTS WHO WERE IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. AS YOU CAN PROBABLY
IMAGINE, PROGRAM EXPANSION AND
CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY HAVE MADE
COMPARING YEAR OVER YEAR CHANGES
IN UPTAKE DIFFICULT AND VERY
HARD TO PREDICT. HOWEVER, TODAY
I WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS
COMPARING THIS FILING SEASON TO
LAST YEAR. LAST YEAR, JUST SHY
OF 80% OF CAL EITC RETURNS WERE
FILED BY APRIL 30TH THIS YEAR AS
OF APRIL 30TH, FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAS PROCESSED OVER 2.9
MILLION RETURNS, CLAIMING THE
CAL EITC. THAT'S UP 7% FROM LAST
YEAR FOR A TOTAL OF 812 MILLION,
WHICH IS ALSO UP 11% OVER LAST
YEAR. AT THE SAME TIME, THE
AVERAGE CREDIT AMOUNT IS ALSO UP
FROM $268 TO $279. THE NUMBER OF
TAXPAYERS CLAIMING THE EITC IS
ALSO UP A MORE MODEST 1% FROM
341,000 RETURNS LAST YEAR
THROUGH APRIL 30TH, TO 344,000
RETURNS THIS YEAR. THE FOSTER
YOUTH TAX CREDIT, WHICH IS IN
ITS SECOND YEAR OF OPERATION,
HAS SEEN A MUCH LARGER JUMP OF
13% OVER ITS FIRST YEAR OF
NEARLY 4100 CLAIMANTS TO NEARLY
4600 THIS YEAR AS OF APRIL 30TH.
FOR I-10 HOLDERS SPECIFICALLY,
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN A RISE IN THE
NUMBER OF CLAIMANTS WITH NEARLY
174,000 CAL EITC CLAIMS. A RISE
OF 4% OVER LAST YEAR AND NEARLY
28,000 ICTC CLAIMS, UP 3% OVER
LAST YEAR. OVER THE YEARS, FTB
HAS ALSO ENGAGED IN MANY
DIFFERENT OUTREACH EFFORTS TO
EDUCATE TAXPAYERS ON EXPANDED
PROVISIONS OF THE ANTI-POVERTY
TAX CREDITS, AS WELL AS
ENCOURAGE THE UPTAKE. IN OUR
2022 REPORT ON THE STUDY. TO
ENCOURAGE OR THE STUDY TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA AND FEDERAL
EITC, FTB IDENTIFIED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OUTREACH TO BOTH
FILERS AND NON-FILERS, APPEARING
TO QUALIFY FOR THE CAL EITC BUT
FAILING TO CLAIM THE CREDIT.
LAST SUMMER, FTB SENT NEARLY
200,000 LETTERS TO NON-FILERS,
PROVIDING A POTENTIAL CREDIT
AMOUNT AND LETTING THEM KNOW IF
THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY
QUALIFIED. THEY SHOULD FILE A
TAX RETURN TO CLAIM THE
REFUNDABLE CREDITS. NEARLY
10,000 TAXPAYERS, OR ALMOST 5,
RESPONDED BY FILING A TAX RETURN
AND RECEIVING 1.6 MILLION IN
CALI EITC REFUNDS IN ADDITION TO
THE TAXABLE YEAR 2022 RETURNS
FILED BY THE FILED IN RESPONSE
TO THE LETTERS THAT WE SENT OUT,
THESE TAXPAYERS ALSO FILED
ANOTHER 3100 RETURNS FOR TAX
YEARS THAT WERE WITHIN THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS AND WERE
ALLOWED AN ADDITIONAL $500,000
IN CALI EITC REFUNDS FOR THIS
OUTREACH PROGRAM. FTB ALSO
LOOKED FOR TAXPAYERS WHO FILED
TAX RETURNS WITH DATA INDICATING
THAT THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CAL EITC, BUT DID NOT CLAIM
IT ON THEIR RETURN FOR THIS
CATEGORY, FTB IDENTIFIED ALMOST
150,000 TAX RETURNS, LETTING
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
KNOW, IF QUALIFIED, TO FILL OUT
A CALI EITC FORM 3514 AND RETURN
IT TO THE FTB. APPROXIMATELY
1500 TAXPAYERS, OR JUST OVER 1,
PROVIDED THE CALI EITC FORM AND
RECEIVED ABOUT $360,000 IN CALI
EITC REFUNDS LAST YEAR. FTB ALSO
PARTNERED WITH OUR SISTER AGENCY
TO PROVIDE NON-FILER FLAGS FOR
THOSE CALFRESH PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS WHO DID NOT FILE A
TAX RETURN DURING 2023, THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REACHED OUT TO OVER 1.4 MILLION
OF THEIR PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
VIA TEXT, EMAIL AND VOICEMAIL
MESSAGES. THEY HAD A RESPONSE
RATE OF ROUGHLY 2.9, WITH AROUND
41,000 PEOPLE RESPONDING. DUE TO
THE LACK OF DATA. HOWEVER, IT IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER, A, IT IS
UNCLEAR HOW MUCH, HOW MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO RESPONDED
TO CS WENT ON TO BOTH FILE A TAX
RETURN AND QUALIFY FOR ANY OF
THE ANTI-POVERTY CREDITS?
ANOTHER IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE
ABOUT ALL OF THE OUTREACH DONE
BY BOTH FTB AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IS THE
MARKETING OF FREE FILING
SERVICES SUCH AS CAL FILE AND
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE VIDA
PROGRAM. THIS YEAR, VIDA
STATISTICS SHOW THAT TO DATE,
FTB HAS RECEIVED OVER 246,000
RETURNS PREPARED BY VIDA
VOLUNTEERS, WHICH IS ONLY ABOUT
2000 LESS THAN THE ENTIRE 2023
TAX YEAR, MAKING THE VIDA
PROGRAM ON TRACK TO EXCEED THE
NUMBER OF VIDA RETURNS RECEIVED
OVER LAST YEAR. AS FTB GEARS UP
FOR 2024 SUMMER OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN, WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH SOCIAL SERVICE SOCIAL
SERVICES TO HELP IDENTIFY
TAXPAYERS WHO MAY QUALIFY.
HOWEVER, FEDERAL PRIVACY RULES
HAVE LIMITED CERTAIN DATA
SHARING BETWEEN OUR AGENCIES. IT
IS ALSO OUR INTENT TO CONTINUE
TO MARKET FREE FILING SERVICES
SUCH AS VIDA AND CAL FILE. AND
WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE, OR
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY FELLOW.
YEP. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT FOR.
ALL RIGHT. FOR UNITED WAY. ARE
THERE PARTICULAR DATA THAT SHOWS
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED USES OF
FUNDS PROGRAMMATICALLY OR
TACTICALLY, OR WHAT WORKS IN
TERMS OF MAKING THOSE? WHAT ARE
THE MOST IMPACTFUL USES? YEAH,
FOR FREE FILING SPECIFICALLY,
I'M SORRY, FOR FREE FILING OR
CAPTURING TAX CREDITS JUST FOR
COMMUNITY OUTREACH FOR OH YEAH,
I MEAN, WE DO. I LIKE TO THINK
OF A LITTLE BIT OF EVERYTHING
WORKS. I MEAN, REALLY WHAT I
THINK CBOS DO BEST IS BUILDING
COMMUNITY TRUST. SO ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR ITIN WORK, THAT'S
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF OUR ITIN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS, THEY MIGHT BE FEARFUL
OF EVEN APPLYING FOR AN ITIN OR
EVEN STARTING THAT PROCESS. SO
OFTEN IT TAKES MULTIPLE TOUCHES.
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO GO OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY, DO SOME EDUCATION AND
THEN GO BACK AGAIN. SO I THINK
WE'RE REALLY STARTING TO SEE AN
UPTICK. I THINK OURS WAS WE SAW
167% INCREASE IN OUR ITIN
APPLICATIONS FROM LAST YEAR,
FROM 2022 TO 2023, WHICH WAS
HUGE. SO I THINK CONSIDERING
THAT THAT PROGRAM STARTED IN
2020, WE SAW SLOW TRACTION. AND
I REALLY THINK THAT WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE MORE MOVEMENT.
WE DO EVERYTHING FROM I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH ARE LIKE, OH, YOU
GUYS ARE JUST PASSING OUT FLIERS
AND PUTTING THINGS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. BUT IT'S REALLY MUCH MORE
THAN THAT. WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
EDUCATIONAL WORKSHOPS. WE'RE
TEACHING PEOPLE HOW TO SELF FILE
THEIR TAXES. WE'RE TEACHING THEM
HOW TO LEARN THE LINGO OF TAXES.
WHAT'S A W-9? WHAT'S A 1099,
THINGS LIKE THAT. AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE A REALLY IMPACTFUL
TEXT MESSAGING PROGRAM. SO WE
HAVE ABOUT 30,000 PEOPLE WHO
HAVE OPTED IN TO RECEIVE TEXT
MESSAGES FROM US JUST FOR TAXES.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE ANY OF
OUR OTHER PROGRAMS. HAVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT THERE? I APOLOGIZE,
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU SORT OF HAVE
AN OVERVIEW OF THAT. YEAH.
ANYWAY, SO PLEASE FEEL FREE.
OKAY. SOUNDS GOOD. SO UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
STATEWIDE GRANTEE FOR BOTH FREE
TAX PREP AND EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS, WE'VE HAD AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING, WHICH HAS LED TO A
DIRECT INCREASE IN IMPACT FOR
EVERY $1 OF INCREASED FUNDING
BETWEEN 2021 AND 2022. IT
RESULTED IN ADDITIONAL DOLLAR
AND $0.50 OF SAVINGS FOR FILERS
ACROSS THE STATE. OVERALL, THE
FUNDING INCREASE OF $5 MILLION
RESULTED IN AN ADDITIONAL
$5,518,000 IN SAVINGS FOR
FILERS. THE 20 MILLION YEAR
ROUND FUNDING WE HAD OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAS HELPED
IMMENSELY INCREASE CAPACITY
ACROSS THE STATE, A 50%
REDUCTION IN FUNDING WOULD BE
DEVASTATING. WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE FUNDING RIGHT AS OUR
OPERATIONS ARE RECOVERING FROM
THE COVID PANDEMIC. FREE TAX
PREP FUNDING HELPS WITH THE
ACTUAL COSTS OF OPERATING A FREE
TAX PREP SITE, WHILE VOLUNTEERS
HELP SAVE ON COSTS, THERE'S AN
IMMENSE AMOUNT OF STAFF TIME
DEDICATED TO RECRUITING,
TRAINING AND MANAGING BOTH
VOLUNTEERS AND PROGRAMING AS A
WHOLE. AS A STATEWIDE SUBGRANTEE
FREE TAX PREP FUNDING HELPS US
MAINTAIN OUR SITE. MY FREE TAXES
ORG, WHICH CONNECTS PEOPLE TO
THREE OF OUR FREE FILING OPTIONS
AN INTERACTIVE MAP, A TAX CREDIT
CALCULATOR, GUIDES, CHECKLISTS
AND RESOURCES. WE ALSO HELP
BUILD STATEWIDE CAPACITY BY
BUILDING UNIVERSAL TOOLS THAT
STREAMLINE PROCESSES AND
INCREASE EFFICIENCY ACROSS THE
NETWORK. WE KNOW FIRSTHAND THE
IMPACT THAT FREE FILING HAS IN
COMMUNITIES, WHICH IS WHY WE
BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR REFUND AND FILE THEIR
TAXES FOR FREE. LAST YEAR,
UNITED WAY PARTNERS IN
CALIFORNIA HELPED SAVE
CALIFORNIANS OVER $32 MILLION IN
FREE TAX PREPARATION FEES.
BESIDES SAVING MONEY ON FREE
FILING, VIÆT ALSO ENSURES THAT
CLIENTS GET EVERY TAX CREDIT
THAT BELONGS TO THEM. WHILE THIS
MAY SEEM LIKE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HAPPEN WITH EVERY
PREPARER, WE HAVE FOUND THAT
THIS ISN'T THE CASE. ACCORDING
TO CAL POLICY LAB, ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE WHO FILE TAXES AND CLAIM
THE FEDERAL EITC, BUT WHO DID
NOT CLAIM THE CAL EITC, 92% HAD
USED AN IN-PERSON PAID TAX
PREPARER. IMAGINE THE IMPACT OF
EVERY PERSON WHO QUALIFIED FOR
TAX CREDITS, GOT WHAT BELONGED
TO THEM. BESIDES TAX CREDITS
BEING ONE OF THE GREATEST
ANTI-POVERTY MEASURES WE HAVE,
STUDIES SHOW THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR INVESTED IN TAX CREDITS
TARGETED AT FAMILIES WITH LOW
INCOMES, $1.50 TO $2 IS DIRECTLY
SPENT IN LOCAL ECONOMIES. IN
2020, THREE, CALIFORNIANS
CLAIMED $1.3 BILLION IN TAX
CREDITS, WHICH MEANS $2.6
BILLION WENT BACK INTO LOCAL
ECONOMIES. OUR EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH EFFORTS PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE SUCCESS OF FREE TAX
PREP. I WOULD ARGUE THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE ONE WITHOUT THE
OTHER. CBOS ARE AT THE HEART OF
VITA AND FREE TAX PREP
OPERATIONS. THEY DO MORE THAN
JUST ATTENDING COMMUNITY EVENTS
AND PASSING OUT FLIERS, BUT
BUILD TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. THIS INCLUDES
BRINGING MOBILE VIÆT BUSSES TO
SOME OF OUR HIGHEST NEED AREAS.
OUR TEXT MESSAGING PROGRAM,
LOCAL PROMOTORAS INTERACTIVE
COMMUNITY WORKSHOPS, AND
BUILDING CULTURALLY COMPETENT
EDUCATIONAL CONTENT. THIS
TRUSTED MESSENGER IS CRITICAL,
PARTICULARLY FOR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LOOKING TO APPLY FOR AN
ITIN VIÆT SITES ARE ARE ONE OF
TWO WAYS TO APPLY FOR AN ITIN
FOR FREE, WITHOUT MAILING IN
HARD COPIES OF YOUR IMMIGRATION
DOCUMENTS, A CERTIFIED
ACCEPTANCE AGENT OR A CAA ACTS
AS A NOTARY, ENSURING THAT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS DON'T HAVE TO
GO MONTHS WITHOUT THEIR
PASSPORTS OR OTHER IMPORTANT
IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS. EVEN WITH
THE IRS MORATORIUM ON CAS, OUR
NETWORKED HELP PROCESS 187% MORE
ITIN APPLICATIONS THAN IN PRIOR
YEARS. OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE A CAA
AT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR VITA
SITES, SO PEOPLE NO LONGER HAVE
TO RELY ON PREDATORY SERVICES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY, WHICH CAN COST
UPWARDS OF $500. WHILE VITA
PROVIDES THESE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO THOUSANDS ACROSS THE
STATE, THERE JUST ISN'T ENOUGH
CAPACITY TO HELP EVERYONE. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE IRS DIRECT FILE
PROGRAM WILL HELP SUPPORT MORE
PEOPLE IN FILING THEIR TAXES FOR
FREE. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
FREE FILING OPTION WILL WORK
WELL ALONGSIDE NOT IN LIEU OF
IDA VITA WILL STILL BE AN
ESSENTIAL SERVICE FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE THE HIGHEST NEED. FOR
EXAMPLE, PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES, PEOPLE WITH
LANGUAGE BARRIERS, PEOPLE WITH
MORE COMPLEX RETURNS, AND PEOPLE
APPLYING FOR OR RENEWING IN
I-10. WE'RE IMMENSELY GRATEFUL
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS OF
EXPANDED FUNDING FOR FREE TAX
PREP AND EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
ON BEHALF OF UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA, THE CALI CALI EITC
COALITION AND CSD GRANTEES, I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT PROTECTING
$20 MILLION IN FUNDING FOR FREE
TAX PREP AND EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I'LL BRING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. THIS INFORMATION ONLY
ITEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND YOUR
PATIENCE. IT WILL TAKE US TO
ISSUE 19 IRS DIRECT FILE REPORT
UPDATE. ALSO INFORMATION ONLY.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN. MY NAME IS
JEANNIE HARRIMAN WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND INVITATION
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE IRS DIRECT
FILE PORTAL. EARLIER THIS YEAR,
THE IRS LAUNCHED THE PILOT
PROGRAM, WHICH ALLOWED TAX
FILERS IN CERTAIN STATES TO FILE
DIRECTLY WITH THE IRS FOR FREE.
THIS PORTAL IS CALLED THE IRS
DIRECT FILE PORTAL. CALIFORNIA
AGREED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PILOT AND UPON COMPLETION OF THE
FEDERAL RETURN, CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WERE DIRECTED TO
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING FILING
APPLICATION CALLED COFF FILE, TO
FILE THEIR CALIFORNIA RETURN. IN
GENERAL, THE IRS DIRECT FILE
PORTAL ALLOWS CERTAIN TAXPAYERS
AN ADDITIONAL TOOL TO FILE THEIR
TAX RETURN FOR FREE DIRECTLY
WITH THE IRS FOR THIS PILOT
YEAR, ONLY TAXPAYERS WITH LESS
COMPLICATED RETURNS WERE
ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE. THOSE
THAT DIDN'T QUALIFY, OR THOSE
WHO CHOSE NOT TO USE THIS NEW
SERVICE IN MANY INSTANCES, COULD
STILL FILE FREE RETURNS BY
SEARCHING FOR A VIÆT SERVICE
NEAR THEM AND USING ONLINE
SOFTWARE PRODUCTS, OR GOING TO A
TAX PROFESSIONAL, I'M SORRY, NOT
A TAX PROFESSIONAL FOR FREE, BUT
THEY'RE USING TOOLS FOR THE FREE
FILE ALLIANCE, WHICH IS A TOOL
SET LISTED ON THE IRS DIRECT
WEBSITE THAT INCLUDES OTHER
SOFTWARE VENDORS. IN THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS, THE IRS HAS
SHARED THE FOLLOWING KEY
INFORMATION ON THE IRS DIRECT
FILE PORTAL. IN THE FOUR MONTHS
IT WAS OPEN, 140,803 FEDERAL
RETURNS WERE ACCEPTED AS FILED.
THAT IS, EXCEEDING THEIR GOAL OF
100,000 RETURNS. THROUGH THE
LIFE OF THIS FIRST YEAR OF THE
PILOT, ACCORDING TO THE IRS. OF
THOSE 140,000, 33,000 OF THOSE
FILERS WERE CALIFORNIANS. SO WE
HAD A VERY WE ACTUALLY HAD THE
LARGEST UPTAKE FOR CALIFORNIANS
ON THE IRS DIRECT FILE PORTAL OF
ANY PARTICIPATING STATE. THEY
NOTED THEIR COST AS WELL. THE
FULL COST, INCLUDING A STUDY
PERIOD FOR THE REPORT THAT WAS
DUE TO CONGRESS IN MAY OF 23, AS
WELL AS SOME MINOR
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS TO GET THE
TOOL OPEN WERE 21.20 4.6 MILLION
TO DATE. THEY INDICATED THEIR
OPERATING COSTS FOR THE PORTAL,
WHICH INCLUDES ABOUT SIX WEEKS.
THIS YEAR FOR LIMITED OPERATION
FOR ELIGIBILITY, AND DURATION OF
TAXPAYERS THAT COULD USE IT, AND
THEN SIX WEEKS APPROXIMATELY OF
BEING AT FULL THROTTLE. ANYBODY
COULD COME IN AT ANY TIME OF THE
DAY AND USE IT. THOSE COSTS FOR
THOSE 12 WEEK PERIOD WAS ABOUT
$2.4 MILLION FOR THEM TO
OPERATE. MOST OF THOSE COSTS
WERE ASSOCIATED WITH CUSTOMER
SERVICE AS WELL AS DATA SECURITY
AND DATA MANIPULATION TOOLS. IN
THE CLOUD. IRS HAS CONSIDERED
THIS PROGRAM TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, IT
EXCEEDED THE EXPECTATIONS AND
EXPECTATIONS OF, NUMBERS COMING
IN, IRS COMMISSIONER WERFUL HAS
COMMITTED TO CONGRESS AND MANY
OTHERS THAT DURING SPRING OF
THIS YEAR THEY WILL ANNOUNCE IF
THEY WILL CONTINUE THE PORTAL
FOR NEXT YEAR AND HOW THEY WILL
DO SO. SO WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WAIT FOR THAT INFORMATION TO
COME THROUGH SO WE CAN DETERMINE
NEXT STEPS, IF ANY, THAT WE HAVE
AS WELL. WE'D ALSO NOTE THE
FOLLOWING OBSERVATIONS, AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED EARLIER, AND
THE PREVIOUS ITEM, VIÆT RETURNS
ARE ON TRACK TO EXCEED PRIOR
YEAR AMOUNTS. WE'VE ALSO SEEN
THAT WITH OUR CAL FILE, RETURNS
ARE ON TRACK TO EXCEED PRIOR
YEAR REFERENCES. AND
COMMISSIONER WERFUL MOST
FAMILIAR WITH THE FREE FILE
ALLIANCE SOFTWARE PRODUCTS, HAS
INDICATED THEY'VE SEEN AN 11%
INCREASE TO DATE. ALL OF THOSE
INCREASES, WHILE NOT
DEFINITIVELY KNOWN, ARE
SUSPECTED TO BE BECAUSE OF THE
MARKETING OF THE FREE FILE TAX
RETURN. THE DIRECT PORTAL,
ENCOURAGED TAXPAYERS TO LOOK
MORE INTO DIRECT FILING. AS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO NEXT STEPS, WE
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE IRS. WE EXPECT THIS WORK TO
ACCELERATE AFTER THE IRS
PROVIDES THIS INFORMATION LATER
THIS SPRING ABOUT THEIR NEXT
STEPS. WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE IRS ABOUT
OPTIONS FOR A FULLY INTEGRATED,
PORTAL, COMMUNICATION CHANNEL
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL PORTAL AND
CAL FILE TO PROVIDE A MORE
SEAMLESS EXPERIENCE FOR THOSE
USING BOTH OF THESE FREE FILING
TOOLS. AFTER ÁP HAS COMPLETED
INITIAL COSTING EXERCISES, WHICH
CURRENTLY RELY ON CRITICAL
ASSUMPTIONS AS TO HOW THE IRS
WILL ENGAGE WITH THE STATES TO
LINK THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND
TOOLS TOGETHER. WE ARE ALSO
DISCUSSING WHEN THE IRS COULD
ASSIST CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE
CRITICAL TO ANY IMPLEMENTATION
WE DO. THE IRS ALSO HAS TO
DEPLOY RESOURCES AT THE SAME
TIME. WE CANNOT BUILD AND LINK
INTO THEIR SYSTEM WITHOUT THEIR
ASSISTANCE. SO WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE AND WILLING TO HELP US
WHEN WE NEED THEM TO. AND OF
COURSE, WHEN FUNDING IS
PRESENTED AS WELL. SO AT THIS
POINT, I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
VERY, VERY MUCH SPECIFICALLY
WITH REGARD TO ALIGNMENT WITH
CAL FILE, WHAT SPECIFIC THINGS
DOES THE DO YOU NEED? DOES THE
DEPARTMENT NEED TO ALIGN WITH
DIRECT FILE, AND WHAT ARE
OPTIONS FOR HOW WE COULD ROLL
THIS OUT? WELL, I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T HEAR THAT LAST PART. WHAT
ARE OPTIONS FOR. YEAH ALIGNING
CAL FILE WITH DIRECT FILE. WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE HURDLES OR
CHALLENGES THAT THE DEPARTMENT
FACES. WHAT ARE THE NEEDS FOR
THAT ALIGNMENT AND HOW COULD
THAT LOOK. YEAH. SO GREAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU FOR
REPEATING THAT. I'M SORRY YOU'RE
LOSING YOUR VOICE. SO, ALLERGIES
I WOULD ASSUME EVERYBODY HAS
ALLERGIES. YES, I KNOW ME MYSELF
AS WELL, SO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES. SO WE ARE IN THE
FORTUNATE POSITION IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE HALF OF
THIS EQUATION BUILT. WE ALREADY
HAVE OUR OWN FREE FILING TOOL
THAT'S BEEN IN DEPLOYED SINCE
THE EARLY 2000, WHICH IS OF
COURSE, CAL FILE AS I MENTIONED.
SO, WHERE OUR ENERGY NEEDS TO
FOCUS ON TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO HOOK UP, IF THAT IS THE
DECISION MADE, IS THAT
COMMUNICATION CHANNEL THAT
ALLOWS TAXPAYERS AND THEIR DATA
TO TRANSIT SAFELY BETWEEN THE
IRS PORTAL AND CALIFORNIA'S
PORTAL. RIGHT, BAD ACTORS ARE
EVERYWHERE. THEY WILL ATTEMPT TO
HIJACK ANY DATA THAT THEY CAN
GET THEIR HANDS ON. SO SECURITY
IS CRITICAL, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE IRS IS PART OF THE
TUNNEL PER SE IS SECURE. AND
THEN WE NEED TO MAKE SURE OUR
PART OF THE TUNNEL IS SECURE AS
WELL, AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DATA COMES OVER
ACCURATELY AND THAT WHEN I
MYSELF MIGHT BE DOING THE IRS,
THAT I MYSELF ACTUALLY MAKE IT
SUCCESSFULLY OVER TO FTB'S
PORTAL, I WASN'T INADVERTENTLY
STEERED TO A ROGUE STATE,
WEBSITE AND THINKING IT'S FTB,
BUT IT REALLY ISN'T. SO SECURITY
IS HUGE ON THAT, WE ALSO NEED TO
UNDERSTAND CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
HOW THE IRS EXPECTS US AND ALL
STATES TO HOOK UP TO THEM. RIGHT
THERE ARE SEVERAL DIFFERENT WAYS
THE IRS COULD NOT SUSTAIN 50
DIFFERENT WAYS TO HOOK UP TO
THEIR SYSTEMS. SO THEY REALLY
NEED TO INDICATE, HOW STATES ARE
EXPECTED TO HOOK UP TO THEM. AND
WHEN THEY CAN DEPLOY RESOURCES
TO ASSIST US IN BUILDING THAT
TUNNEL THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
AS FAR AS ALLOWING FOR THE, THE
CONDUIT OF DATA AND TAXPAYERS
THROUGH BETWEEN THE TWO SYSTEMS.
SO THOSE ARE THE BUILD PART OF
THE APPLICATIONS THAT WERE,
STRUGGLING WITH NOW NEEDING MORE
DATA, NEEDING SOME UNDERSTANDING
OF TIME FRAMES, ETC. THE OTHER
COMPLEXITY THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE IS CUSTOMER SERVICE, THE
IRS HAS DEPLOYED, AS THEY'VE
INDICATED IN THEIR REPORT TO
CONGRESS IN MAY OF 2023, I'LL
JUST CALL IT AN EXTRAORDINARY
LEVEL OF CUSTOMER SERVICE, NOT
THAT IT IS UNDESERVING, BUT IT
IS EXTRAORDINARY LEVEL. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TYPICAL LEVEL OF
SERVICE, THE IRS PROVIDES AND
EVEN WE PROVIDE TO OUR EXISTING
CUSTOMERS TODAY AT FTB. SO THAT
IS ANOTHER COMMENT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT INTERNAL TO OUR
OWN ORGANIZATION. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING WITH YOU
FOLKS WHO WOULD FUND US TO DO
THIS, WHAT IS THE EXPECTED LEVEL
OF SERVICE THAT WE WOULD DO WITH
THESE TAXPAYERS? THEY'RE TRYING
TO FILE THEIR RETURNS. THEY NEED
TO BE ENGAGED AND KEPT ENGAGED.
THEY DON'T WANT TO WAIT FOR AN
HOUR TO SOMEBODY TO PICK UP THE
PHONE TO HELP THEM FINISH THAT
LAST BIT OF THEIR RETURN, SO IT
IS A CRUCIAL CONVERSATION TO BE
HAVING. SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD SAY ARE PROBABLY
MOST RELEVANT TO WHAT YOU'RE
SPEAKING TO. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THAT'LL BRING US TO ISSUE 20
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR FIX.
MUSICAL CHAIRS AGAIN.
GO AHEAD AND PROCEED WHILE I'M
READY. OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON,
NICK THOMAS AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A PROPOSAL
WHICH CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
THAT WHEN A CORPORATION RECEIVES
INCOME THAT IS EXCLUDED FROM
TAXABLE INCOME, THEN IT MUST
EXCLUDE THIS INCOME FROM ITS
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR FORMULA,
DISCUSSED IT A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER WITH REGARD TO LAWS,
POTENTIAL PROPOSALS, BUT AN
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR ESSENTIALLY
REPRESENTS THE SHARE OF BUSINESS
ACTIVITY A FIRM CONDUCTS IN A
STATE DIVIDED BY ITS TOTAL
BUSINESS ACTIVITY, ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. AND THAT THEN
DETERMINES HOW MUCH OF ITS
INCOME IS THEN APPORTIONED TO
EACH STATE, CONSISTENT WITH
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES WHICH
SEEK AN EQUITABLE AND REASONABLE
, METHOD FOR TAXING CORPORATIONS
THAT DO BUSINESS IN MULTIPLE
STATES AND COUNTRIES, THE FTB
HAS PREVIOUSLY ISSUED LONG
STANDING AND CONSISTENT GUIDANCE
TO TAXPAYERS THAT ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE NOT SUBJECT TO TAXATION
, IF THEY GENERATE INCOME, ARE
REQUIRED TO BE EXCLUDED FROM THE
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA, HOWEVER,
IN RECENT LEGAL RULINGS, THE
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS HAS
DETERMINED THAT EXISTING STATUTE
IS UNCLEAR, ON HOW CERTAIN NON
TAXABLE INCOME SHOULD BE
TREATED, AND THIS HAS LED TO
SOME REFUNDS BEING ISSUED TO
TAXPAYERS RELATED TO PAST TAX
YEARS, THE ISSUE BECAME
PARTICULARLY RELEVANT FOLLOWING
THE FEDERAL TAX CUTS AND JOBS
ACT, WHICH PROVIDED AN INCENTIVE
FOR CORPORATIONS TO REPATRIATE
LARGE AMOUNTS OF FOREIGN SOURCED
DIVIDENDS FROM THEIR
INTERNATIONAL SUBSIDIARIES,
CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS 75% OF
THOSE DIVIDENDS TO BE DEDUCTED
FROM INCOME, MEANING THAT THAT
PORTION IS NOT TAXED. HOWEVER,
TAXPAYERS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ARGUED THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO COUNT THE ENTIRE AMOUNT OF
THOSE DIVIDENDS IN THE
DENOMINATOR OF THEIR
APPORTIONMENT FORMULA, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY SHOULD NORMALLY
REPRESENT THEIR TOTAL BUSINESS
ACTIVITY, HOWEVER, SINCE 75% OF
THESE DIVIDENDS ARE NOT ACTUALLY
TAXED IN CALIFORNIA, THAT HAS
ALLOWED TAXPAYERS TO
ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THEIR
CALCULATED CALIFORNIA SHARE OF
OVERALL BUSINESS ACTIVITY, WHICH
IN TURN RESULTED IN A REDUCTION
OF THEIR TAX OWED SIMPLY BY
HAVING MORE FOREIGN DIVIDENDS,
THIS PROPOSAL IS DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW AND SEEKS TO
PROVIDE CLEAR STATUTORY
AUTHORITY AND GUIDELINES TO
TAXPAYERS ON HOW TO DETERMINE,
WHAT INCOME SHOULD BE INCLUDED
IN THEIR APPORTIONMENT FACTOR.
IT WOULDN'T OVERTURN ANY PRIOR
SPECIFIC TAXPAYER CASES, BUT
WOULD INSTEAD BE CONSIDERED IN
FUTURE CASES. ADDITIONALLY, IT
PREVENTS A LOOPHOLE WHERE
TAXPAYERS COULD INCLUDE
NONTAXABLE INCOME IN THEIR
APPORTIONMENT BASE TO REDUCE
THEIR TAX LIABILITY, THE FTB
ESTIMATES THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY $1.3 BILLION IN
POTENTIAL REFUND CLAIMS FROM
PAST YEARS THAT ARE AT RISK IF
NO LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS TAKEN
TO CLARIFY STATUTE, AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY, THERE'S A
PROSPECTIVE POTENTIAL ONGOING
REFUND CLAIMS OF $200 MILLION
PER YEAR GOING FORWARD. FINANCE
ESTIMATES, THAT WITHOUT THIS
PROPOSAL, ABOUT HALF OF THOSE
$1.3 BILLION, IN PAST REFUNDS
WOULD BE ISSUED TO TAXPAYERS
THROUGHOUT THE MULTI YEAR BUDGET
WINDOW, AS ADDITIONAL LEGAL
CASES AND REFUND CLAIMS ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD BY TAXPAYERS, OF
THAT, THE MAY REVISION FORECAST
ASSUMES THAT REVENUES WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY $216 MILLION LOWER
IN THE BUDGET WINDOW, AND THEN
THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE LOSSES OUTSIDE THE
BUDGET WINDOW, AND THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE WOULD
PREVENT THOSE LOSSES AND WOULD
BRING CORPORATION REVENUES BACK
TO WHAT THEY WOULD BE WITHOUT
THE DISTORTIONS FROM THE
ALTERNATIVE COMPUTATION OF THE
APPORTIONMENT FACTOR. WITH THAT,
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. NO CONCERNS ON THIS
ITEM. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THAT'LL MOVE US ON TO ISSUE 21,
DISASTER RELIEF, THANK YOU.
COLBY WHITE, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO THIS IS THE
CONFORMITY DISASTER RELIEF
PROPOSAL. AND SO BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND, UNDER EXISTING LAW,
THE INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE CAN
GRANT FEDERAL TAX RELIEF IN THE
FORM OF CERTAIN DELAYED TAX
FILING OR PAYMENT DEADLINES TO
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE COVERED BY A
DISASTER THAT IS DECLARED BY THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY. AND UNDER EXISTING LAW,
THE STATE HAS THE OPTION TO
FULLY CONFORM, PARTIALLY CONFORM
OR NOT CONFORM AT ALL TO THOSE
DELAYED DEADLINES. SO IN RECENT
YEARS, THE IRS HAS EXTENDED TAX
FILING AND PAYMENT DEADLINES
MULTIPLE TIMES DUE TO DISASTER
DECLARATIONS, INCLUDING LAST
YEAR FOLLOWING A, THIS A SERIES
OF WINTER STORMS IN JANUARY
2023. SO IN THAT CASE, THE IRS
ENDED UP DELAYING VARIOUS TAX
FILING AND PAYMENT DEADLINES TO
NOVEMBER 2023. SOME DEADLINES
WERE EXTENDED AS LONG AS TEN
MONTHS. ULTIMATELY IMPACTED 55
OF 58 COUNTIES AND OVER 99% OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION. SO THIS
PARTICULAR EXTENSION WAS OVERLY
BROAD AND IN BOTH IN TERMS OF
SCOPE AND THE LENGTH OF THE
DELAY AS JUST 15 OF THOSE
COUNTIES WERE ACTUALLY WERE
QUALIFIED FOR INDIVIDUAL
ASSISTANCE, WHICH MEANS
INDIVIDUALS OR HOUSEHOLDS WERE
IMPACTED, WHILE THE REMAINING
COUNTIES WERE PUBLIC ASSISTANCE,
WHICH MEANS THAT IT WAS ONLY A
PUBLIC ENTITIES THAT WERE
IMPACTED BY THE DISASTER, SO
THIS PARTICULAR OVERLY BROAD AND
UNPRECEDENTED EXTENSION FROM
LAST YEAR HAD A SIGNIFICANT,
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS TO THE
STATE, NORMALLY THE BULK OF CASH
DATA IS KNOWN AT THE TIME. THE
MAY REVISION FORECAST IS DONE.
THAT WASN'T THE CASE LAST YEAR.
AND AS A RESULT, THE MAJORITY OF
THE REVENUE DOWNTURN WASN'T
APPARENT TO US UNTIL THE
COLLECTIONS. THE CASH
COLLECTIONS CAME IN IN OCTOBER
AND NOVEMBER. AND SO THIS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT DETRIMENTAL IMPACT
IN THE SENSE THAT THE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BUDGET THAT
WERE REQUIRED AS A RESULT OF
THAT, WHEN WE WERE AWARE OF THE
REVENUE DOWNTURN OCCURRED, MUCH
LATER IN THE PROCESS, WE WERE
IN, YOU KNOW, THE PERSON IN THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL, WE STARTED TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS AS FAR AS, WHEREAS
WE COULD HAVE BEEN MAKING THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE PRIOR BUDGET,
FOR THE 2324 FISCAL YEAR. SO
THIS PROPOSAL DOES TWO THINGS.
IT, IT SHIFTS THE AUTHORITY FROM
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AND TO WHAT EXTENT THE
STATE WILL CONFORM TO DELAYED
DEADLINES IN THE FUTURE FOR THE
IRS, IT DOESN'T CHANGE EXISTING
LAW IN THE SENSE THAT WE STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO EITHER
PARTIALLY CONFORM, FULLY CONFORM
, OR, OR NOT CONFORM AT ALL
THAT, THAT, THAT, THAT, THAT
EXISTS IN CURRENT LAW, SECONDLY,
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT ADDS IT
ADDS A NEW INDIVIDUALIZED
PROCESS FOR TAXPAYERS, TO GET
RELIEF IN THE CASES WHERE THEY
MAY HAVE HAPPENED TO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED. BUT THE STATE DECIDES
NOT TO FULLY CONFORM IN, IN THAT
PARTICULAR IN THE JURISDICTION
SO THAT IT ADDS A NEW PROCESS TO
GRANT RELIEF TO TAXPAYERS. AND,
OVERALL, THIS IS A YOU KNOW,
WE'RE LOOKING WE THINK THIS IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND AND, AND THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE FINANCE
TO MAKE THIS DETERMINATION
THÀNH. ALTHOUGH WE ENVISION IT
BEING IN CONSULTATION WITH FTB
AND CARLOS, BUT IF SUCH A
DECISION WERE MADE, IT WOULD BE
ON THE BASIS OF, FISCAL IMPACTS
TO THE STATE BUDGET PLANNING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. SO WITH THAT,
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL, THAT BEING
SAID, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER,
THAT THE STATE'S TAX SYSTEM
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN SORT OF
ITS ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
FIRMLY LINKED TO THE IRS, SUCH
THAT THE KIND OF CONTEMPLATED
DECOUPLING HERE IN THIS PROPOSAL
STILL HAS SOME RISK OF RAISING
CONFUSION OR FRUSTRATION AMONG
TAXPAYERS, YOU KNOW, THAT THAT
POTENTIAL RISK HAS TO BE WEIGHED
AGAINST THE, THE, THE POTENTIAL
KIND OF BUDGET PROCESS BENEFITS
THAT COULD COME FROM, ALLOWING
THE SORT OF MECHANISM TO BE PUT
IN PLACE. COMMITTEE. I WOULD
JUST SAY, LOOK, I GET THE
PROBLEM, IT'S BEEN PROBLEMATIC
FOR THE LEGISLATURE, FOR THE
GOVERNOR, CERTAINLY OUT OF OUR
CONTROL TO SOME EXTENT. EXCUSE
ME. MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT TO
THE LÀ POINT, THIS IS A
DIFFICULT THING TO ADMINISTER,
POTENTIALLY. AND THAT
INCONGRUENCE MAY CREATE OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES AND
COSTS. AND YOU ADDRESS THAT A
LITTLE BIT. YEAH, I WOULD JUST I
WOULD FIRST POINT OUT THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW, SO WE THE STATE HAS
THE ABILITY TO PARTIALLY CONFORM
OR NOT CONFORM. SO THAT THAT'S
NOT CHANGING. SO THIS LAW IS NOT
CHANGING. IT DOES SHIFT THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE THAT DECISION
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THE PRIORITY WILL ALWAYS BE TO
PROVIDE RELIEF, RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS, THAT NEED IT. AND
THAT'S WHY THE INDIVIDUALIZED
PROCESS IS ON TOP. IT'S JUST IN
THE AND, YOU KNOW, HOPEFULLY WE
NEVER NEED THIS. YOU KNOW,
HOPEFULLY THE, YOU KNOW, THE
WHAT THE IRS DID LAST YEAR WAS,
WAS OVERLY BROAD. IT AFFECTED,
YOU KNOW, THE RELIEF BEING
PROVIDED TO COUNTIES THAT WERE
NOT IN INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE
COUNTIES WAS REALLY WAS REALLY
NOT NOT NECESSARY. SO IN THE
SENSE OF, AND THEN I THINK
GETTING TO YOUR FINAL QUESTION
OR POINT, AS FAR AS THE
POTENTIAL CONFUSION FOR
TAXPAYERS, CERTAINLY THERE WILL
HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR
COMMUNICATION, OUTREACH AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT. BUT I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THE
TAXPAYERS WERE VERY CONFUSED.
ANYWAYS, THIS LAST TIME, I MEAN,
I HAVE ANECDOTES WHERE PEOPLE
WERE GIVEN IRS NOTICES THAT
THEY, YOU KNOW, THEY HAD A
PAYMENT DUE IN JULY. I MEAN,
THINGS WHEN DEADLINES GET
DELAYED, THERE'S CONFUSION. SO
EVEN IF THE STATE WERE TO
CONFORM FULLY TO DEADLINES IN
CERTAIN COUNTIES IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THE IRS AND YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN EXTENSION THAT DOESN'T
COVER THE WHOLE STATE, THERE'S
GOING TO BE CONFUSION. SO IT'LL
BE BUT THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
WILL CERTAINLY PRIORITIZE
COMMUNICATIONS, MESSAGING AND
TRYING TO LIMIT THAT CONFUSION
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. SENATOR
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR WORKING
THROUGH, THAT COLD AND ALLERGY
COMBINATION. SO, MY QUESTION IS
ABOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS
DEADLINE. SO I'M UNDERSTANDING
SORT OF WHO MAKES THE DECISION
AND THE TERMINATION AND THOSE
PIECES. BUT HOW DO WE GET TO
HAVING A BETTER SORT OF PICTURE
OF RECEIPTS FOR OUR BUDGET
MAKING PROCESS? I'M UNCLEAR
ABOUT WHERE THE TIMING HAPPENS.
I UNDERSTAND WHO MAKES THE
DECISION AND THE COMMUNICATION
WITH IRS, BUT JUST ARE WE
REALIGNING DEADLINES SO THAT IF
YOU'RE YOU ARE, IMPACTED IN
THESE COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE'S
BEEN A STATE OF EMERGENCY THAT
SOMEHOW THE FILING HAPPENS, THAT
GIVES US A SENSE OF WHAT OUR
BUDGET PICTURE WILL LOOK LIKE.
I'M JUST I'M JUST CURIOUS, HOW
DOES THE DEADLINE GET AFFECTED
BY THIS? OKAY. SO. WELL, SO THE
FIRST PART IS, IS GENERALLY WHEN
WE'RE DOING THE, THE MAY
REVISION FORECAST, THE APRIL THE
APRIL FILING DEADLINE IS, IS
AROUND MID-APRIL. AND THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT, DEADLINE. IT
CONCLUDES THE PAYMENTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THE PRIOR TAX YEAR
AND GIVES US A GOOD PICTURE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THAT TAX
YEAR. SO WHAT WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
IS DOING IS IN THE CASE WHERE
THERE IS A DISASTER AND THE IRS
WERE TO EXTEND DEADLINES, THIS
PROVIDES THE WELL, I MEAN
EXISTING LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
THIS. IT PROVIDES THE ABILITY.
SO IF THEY EXTEND IT PAST THE
APRIL DEADLINE, THE STATE HAS
THE OPTION TO CONFORM OR NOT
CONFORM OR PARTIALLY CONFORM. SO
WE THE PRIORITY HERE IS ALWAYS
TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO PEOPLE THAT
NEED IT. SO THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE IS WHEN
THERE'S AN OVERLY BROAD AND
THERE'S RELIEF BEING PROVIDED TO
TWO THIRDS OF THE STATE, MAYBE.
AND THAT REALLY DOESN'T NEED IT.
AND IN THAT CASE, THOSE TWO
THIRDS OF THOSE RECEIPTS, WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE.
IN APRIL. AND THEN IT AFFECTS
BUDGET DECISIONS. PROGRAMS ARE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. WE CAN'T,
YOU KNOW, CAN'T RIGHTSIZE THE
BUDGET APPROPRIATELY,
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE'RE
FORECASTING OFF OF A OFF OF A
VERY VOLATILE TIME PERIOD. SO
REALLY, IT'S JUST IT'S JUST TO
PUT FORTH A PROCESS THAT YOU
KNOW, ENABLES US POTENTIALLY TO
PROVIDE MORE TARGETED RELIEF.
AND THE, THE, THE INDIVIDUALIZED
RELIEF THAT'S ADDED TO THIS IS
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY TAXPAYER
THAT IS IMPACTED, IF THERE IS BY
CHANCE, SOMEBODY THAT DOESN'T
GET THE EXTENDED DEADLINE, THAT
THE STATE DOESN'T EXTEND THEIR
DEADLINES IN A PARTICULAR COUNTY
BECAUSE IT DETERMINES THAT
COUNTY IN THE AGGREGATE WAS NOT
WAS NOT SIGNIFICANTLY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. IT'S STILL ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO COME FORWARD AND
PROVIDE SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION
UPON REQUEST OF THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. AND STILL GET THAT
EXTENDED DEADLINE RELIEF, IF
THEY TRULY WERE WERE IMPACTED.
SO IT'S JUST IN IN A SITUATION
THÀNH WHERE WE MIGHT NEED TO BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE TARGETED,
PARTICULARLY IN THE EXAMPLE FROM
LAST YEAR, IS A CASE IN POINT ON
THAT. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
I'M UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE JUST
SAYING THEN THAT THE WE HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF EXACTLY WHAT
PERCENT OR NUMBER OF TAXPAYERS
IS. THIS GIVES US AN OPTION TO,
TO SORT OF BE MORE TARGETED AND
UNDERSTANDING WHO IS GOING TO BE
DELAYED AND WHAT THE PROJECTED
SORT OF DELAY LAY IN HAVING A
MORE ACCURATE PICTURE. I GUESS
I'M STILL NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW
IT IT GIVES DEFINITELY MORE
OPTIONS, AND I UNDERSTAND HOW IT
HELPS TO SUPPORT AND PROTECT
THOSE THOSE THOSE TAXPAYERS. I'M
BUT IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY CHANGE
THE SENSE IN TERMS OF WHEN THOSE
RECEIPTS WILL WILL COME IN. IT
JUST HELPS US PROJECT AND KNOW
MORE PRECISELY WHEN WE'LL HAVE A
SNAPSHOT OF WHEN THOSE RECEIPTS
WILL COME IN. I'M JUST I'M
TRYING TO SEE HOW IT HELPS US
NOT REPEAT WHAT WE JUST WENT
THROUGH IN THE BUDGET PROCESS.
IF WE GO BACK TO LAST YEAR, THEN
, IF WE HAD PROVIDED MORE
TARGETED RELIEF AND WE HADN'T,
IT HADN'T BEEN 99% OF THE
POPULATION HAD EXTENDED
DEADLINES. SO IT HAD BEEN SOME
MUCH SMALLER PERCENTAGE THEN WE
WOULD HAVE WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN A
LOT MORE. BUT WHEN WE WERE
PREPARING THE MAY REVISION
FORECAST, BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE MADE
MUCH EARLIER PROGRAMS. IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH LESS DISRUPTIVE
TO PROGRAMS. THE IDEA, BUT STILL
IS TO PROVIDE WOULD BE TO
PROVIDE THAT RELIEF TO THE
TAXPAYERS THAT TRULY NEEDED IT.
AS PART OF THOSE. BUT IN THE
CASE WHERE 99% OF THE STATE, YOU
KNOW, AND THEN AND THEN OTHER
EXAMPLES IN, IN THE COVID
EXAMPLE, YES, EVERYONE GOT
RELIEF AND PROBABLY EVERYONE
NEEDED IT, RIGHT? SO SOMETIMES
YOU'RE JUST NOT YOU'RE JUST
GOING TO BE FLYING BLIND. BUT
THE IDEA IS NOT TO FLY BLIND
UNLESS UNLESS YOU HAVE TO. GOT
IT. THANKS FOR THE MOST PART, IN
THIS PARTICULAR SCENARIO, THE
RECEIPTS ARE THE DATA, SO IT'S A
DOUBLE. YEAH IN FACT, IN TERMS
OF THE ABILITY TO FORECAST AND
PLAN, BUT ALSO TO HAVE RECEIPTS
IN HAND. AND I GET THAT MY
CONCERN JUST REITERATING WAS
THAT IF WE GO TO INDIVIDUAL
TARGETED SORT OF CHOOSING
NON-ALIGNMENT, THERE'S AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENT THERE
THAT WE, YOU KNOW, TAXPAYERS
HAVE A BURDEN TO PRODUCE
DOCUMENTATION. SO THERE'S SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPACT ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT DECOUPLING. AS THE, LÀ
Þ TERMED IT EARLIER, WHICH I
DON'T WANT TO LOSE TRACK OF.
SENATOR NHIÀU HÌ. REFERENCING
THE 2324 BUDGET AS IT WAS
ADOPTED IN JUNE OF 2023. WHAT
WAS THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
BUDGET'S REVENUE PROJECTION
VERSUS WHAT THE LAO HAD OPINED
PRIOR IN ITS ANALYSIS OF
PROBABLY THE MAY REVISE? YOU
KNOW, SENATOR, IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION THAT I SHOULD HAVE ON
TOP OF IT WAS, IT WAS OVER $15
BILLION DIFFERENCE. I CAN'T
RECALL THE EXACT NUMBER. 15
BILLION. YEAH. AND WHAT WAS THE
SHORTFALL DISCOVERED IN NOVEMBER
FOR? IT WAS MUCH LARGER THAN
THAT. WELL, I UNDERSTAND, I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT THE NUMBER
WAS. I I WILL GET YOU THE
PRECISE NUMBER FOLLOWING THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING. WELL, THERE'S
A POINT TO MY QUESTION. I THINK
IT'S OBVIOUS BASED UPON THE
ANSWER. LAST YEAR AND I'M
CONCERNED THIS YEAR. WELL, FIRST
OF ALL, A REALLY EASY WAY TO
BALANCE A PUBLIC SECTOR BUDGET
IS TO JUST FORECAST MORE REVENUE
. AND THERE IS A TERRIBLE
TEMPTATION FOR BUDGET WRITERS TO
DO THAT. I'VE BEEN THROUGH SIX
BUDGET CYCLES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
, AND NOW SEVEN BUDGET CYCLES AT
THE STATE LEVEL. AND WHEN WE
FALL ON HARD TIMES FOR THOSE WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR ACTUALLY
WRITING THE BUDGET, THERE IS A
REAL TEMPTATION TO TRY TO SOLVE
SOME OF THE PROBLEM BY, REVENUE
PROJECTIONS. AND I DON'T MEAN
THAT IT'S NECESSARILY
INTENTIONAL, BUT THERE'S A
NATURAL TENDENCY. AND THE LAO,
AS A BUDGET ADVISOR, DOESN'T
HAVE THAT KIND OF PRESSURE. AND
SO LAST YEAR WE OVERESTIMATED
REVENUE. I REALIZE THAT THE
UNKNOWN FACTOR, WAS UNKNOWN, BUT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY VÌ THE
PROJECTIONS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
MORE CONSERVATIVE, BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T KNOW. AND IF REVENUES
ENDED UP BEING AS WE ORIGINALLY
THOUGHT THEY WERE, HAPPY DAYS,
THEN WE ADJUST THINGS IN
NOVEMBER, BUT WE GET TO ADJUSTED
THE OTHER WAY, SO I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE PROBLEM THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
FIX MIGHT BE AT LEAST PARTIALLY
OVEROPTIMISM WITH REGARD TO
BUDGET WRITING, AND I KIND OF
SEE THE SAME THING HAPPENING
THIS YEAR. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ALL RIGHT, THIS ITEM
WILL BE HELD OPEN. EXCUSE MY
VOICE, I'M HANGING IN THERE.
THAT'LL BRING US TO, LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCING ISSUE 22
VLF BACKFILL
.
MR. IS THIS A GOOD. NAME TITLES
FOR THE RECORD AND PROCEED, GOOD
MORNING, CHRIS HILL, OR GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHRIS HILL.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CAROLYN
CHIU, LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I'D BE HAPPY TO LEAD IT
OFF, THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
BACKGROUND TO THE ISSUE THAT'S
BEFORE US TODAY AT A HIGH LEVEL,
WE HAVE FROM THREE COUNTIES IN
THE STATE, SAN MATEO, ALPINE AND
MONO COUNTY. A REQUEST FOR A
TOTAL OF APPROXIMATELY $72.5
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO BACKFILL
WHAT IS KNOWN AS, INSUFFICIENT
ERAF AND THIS ALL HAS TO DO WITH
VEHICLE LICENSE FEE BACKFILL
REQUIREMENTS. AND JUST TO TRY
AND GIVE A HIGH LEVEL QUICK
OVERVIEW, EACH COUNTY HAS AN
EDUCATIONAL REVENUE AUGMENTATION
FUND OR AN ERAF AND COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLERS EACH YEAR
SHIFT TO SPECIFIED, STATUTORILY
SPECIFIED AMOUNT OF PROPERTY TAX
FROM CITIES, COUNTIES, AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND PLACE THAT
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE INTO THE
ERAF FOR ALLOCATION TO THE K-14
SCHOOLS IN THAT COUNTY. ONE OF
THE RULES OF THE ERAF IS THAT
ERAF MONEY CANNOT GO TO SCHOOLS
THAT ARE CALLED BASIC AID, THAT
ARE FUNDED TO THE REVENUE LIMITS
OR THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA LIMITS SOLELY WITH
PROPERTY TAX. SO IF YOU HAVE A
BASIC AID SCHOOL AND IT IT
CANNOT ABSORB THAT ERAF THE ERAF
IS TRANSFERRED THAT ERAF MONEY
IS TRANSFERRED BACK TO THE DONOR
CITY AND COUNTY AND SPECIAL
DISTRICT. AND THAT'S ONE THING
THAT'S KIND OF IMPORTANT TO BEAR
IN MIND AS WE DELVE INTO THIS
ISSUE. AND, IN 2003, WHEN
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER REDUCED
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE FROM 2%
TO 0.65, STATUTE WAS
SUBSEQUENTLY ENACTED TO BACKFILL
THAT LOST VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUE FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES.
IT WAS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE SOURCE. AND SO HOW IT
WORKS IS CITIES AND COUNTIES,
CAN TAKE BACK FROM THE ERAF THE
MONEY THEY PUT IN TO BACKFILL
THEIR LOST VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUE. AND THEN IF THERE'S
STILL A NEED, IF THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO FULLY COVER THEIR VLF
BACKFILL OBLIGATION, WHAT
HAPPENS IS THE COUNTY AUDITOR
CONTROLLER THEN TAKES PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE FROM NON BASIC AID
SCHOOLS AND GIVES IT TO THE
CITIES AND TO THE COUNTY. AND
THE $72.5 MILLION AT ISSUE.
LET'S LET'S PRETEND WE HAVE A
COUNTY AND THEY HAVE, THERE'S
$100 IN THE EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUND AND JUST FOR
EASE OF SIMPLICITY, FOR SCENARIO
, THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
BACKFILL AMOUNT OWED TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES IS ALSO $100. SO
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS THE COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLER JUST TAKES
THAT MONEY FROM THE ERAF GIVES
IT TO THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES. BUT LET'S PRETEND THAT
$10 OF THAT $100 WAS ERAF THAT
COULD NOT BE ABSORBED BY BASIC
AID SCHOOLS. SO IN THAT CASE,
THE $100 BACKFILL GOES TO THE
CITIES AND THE COUNTIES. BUT
THAT $10 UNDER STATUTE CANNOT
COUNT TOWARDS BACKFILLING THE
VLF OBLIGATION. SO THE COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLER THEN SHIFTS
ANOTHER $10 FROM THE COUNTY'S
NON BASIC AID K 14 SCHOOLS, AND
GIVES IT TO THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES AND SO BY BY FUNCTION
OF THAT STATUTE, EVEN THOUGH THE
VLF BACKFILL OBLIGATION FOR THE
COUNTY AND FOR THE CITIES IS
$100, THEY'RE REALLY GETTING
110. AND IT IS FINANCES, BELIEF
THAT THE $72.5 MILLION AT ISSUE
HERE IS ESSENTIALLY THAT $10. SO
FINANCE UNDERSTANDS THIS,
PARTICULARLY IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY, THAT THE COUNTY AND THE
CITIES ARE BEING FULLY
BACKFILLED FOR THEIR VLF
OBLIGATION, BUT THEY ARE NOT
GETTING THIS EXTRA. THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH MONEY TO TAKE FROM THE
NON-BASIC AID SCHOOLS TO COVER
THIS ADDITIONAL EXCESS ERAF. AND
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT IS WHAT
THIS $72.5 MILLION REQUEST
PRIMARILY IS FOR THE $72.5
MILLION, ABOUT $69 MILLION IS
FOR SAN MATEO COUNTY, THE STATE
HAD A PRACTICE OF FUNDING THIS
AS A BEST PRACTICE IN THE PAST,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT STATUTORILY
REQUIRED TO DO SO. BUT GIVEN
RECENT BUDGET CYCLES AND THE
INCREASING FISCAL DIFFICULTIES
THAT WE'RE ALL AWARE OF, THE
STATE HAD THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
OPTED TO NOT PROVIDE THOSE
BACKFILLS ANY LONGER. AND WITH
THAT, I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HAS. THANK YOU. IS THERE
AGREEMENT THAT THERE IS AN
OBLIGATION TO BACKFILL IN THE
FIRST PLACE? AND SECONDARILY,
WHAT'S THE FUTURE OUTLOOK LOOK
LIKE? ARE WE LOOKING AT
COMPROMISES, I WOULD JUST AGAIN
NOTE THAT THERE'S NOT A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT THAT THIS
BE DONE THERE WHEN THE STATUTES
WERE ENACTED, THIS SCENARIO
APPARENTLY WAS NOT ENVISIONED.
SO IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THERE.
SO THERE ISN'T A REQUIREMENT
THAT WE DO SO. AND THE BACKFILL
AMOUNT JUST VARIES FROM YEAR TO
YEAR BASED PRIMARILY ON HOW MANY
SCHOOLS OR BASIC AID. AND THAT'S
A FACTOR DRIVEN PRIMARILY BY,
ASSESSED VALUE INCREASES FOR
PROPERTY TAX PURPOSES AND FOR
AND BY ENROLLMENT CHANGES IN THE
SCHOOLS. SO WE HAVE NOTHING TO
ADD ON THIS ITEM, BUT HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. WE WILL MOVE
US TO WE'LL MOVE RIGHT ALONG THE
ITEM WILL BE HELD. TAKE US TO
ISSUE 23 BUSINESS, CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY.
COME ON DOWN. ISSUE 23 IS CUTS
TO SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FROM
ROUND FIVE OF CHAP. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KAYLEE. KAYLEE. AMP,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSED TO DELAY $260 MILLION
IN HALF. ROUND FIVE FUNDING FROM
2023 TO 24 TO, 20 2526. HOWEVER
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION NOW
PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE THIS
FUNDING AND SAID. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ANY
COMMENT FROM LAO OR ANALYSIS FOR
CAROLYN CHU? ELIO THIS
PARTICULAR REVISION PROPOSAL
MEANS THERE WILL BE LESS FUNDING
FOR HARP IN THE OUT YEARS. THIS
IS A RELATIVE TO JANUARY. THIS
IS A 2526, ISSUE, SO A KEY
QUESTION, I THINK, FOR OUR
OFFICE IS WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ANTICIPATES THE
ROUND FIVE FUNDING WOULD BE
FULLY EXPENDED AS A WAY TO HELP
THE LEGISLATURE THINK THROUGH
THIS PARTICULAR REDUCTION
PROPOSAL. WE DID HAVE AN AUDIT,
BUT IT LOOKED AT ROUND ONE AND
LOOKED AT THE QUESTION OF, WE
NEED GREATER REPORTING AND DATA
COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS. AND HOW
DOES SUSPENSION OR DELAY ON THIS
ROUND OR ELIMINATIONS GOING
FORWARD AFFECT THE ABILITY TO
BASICALLY MEET THAT STANDARD?
THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSED
REDUCTION WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT
ON ACCOUNTABILITY OR ANYTHING OF
THAT NATURE. WE DO NOTE THAT
THIS IS FUNDING THAT HASN'T BEEN
APPLIED FOR YET, AND IT HASN'T
BEEN NO APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED. AND THE FUNDING WAS
NOT ANTICIPATED TO FLOW IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. AND SO WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSED
REDUCTION WOULD HAVE ANY IMPACT
ON, CURRENT SERVICE LEVELS, IT'S
NOT A IT'S NOT A REDUCTION. THE
ADMINISTRATION, IS PLEASED TO
PROPOSE, BUT WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THE OVERALL BUDGET SITUATION,
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A COMPONENT
TO ACHIEVING A BALANCED BUDGET.
AND, ALSO IN TERMS OF THE AUDIT,
I BELIEVE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
SAID ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS, AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS SAID
THAT, THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COMMITTED TO, ACCEPT THE
FINDINGS OF THE AUDIT AND IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING TO ENHANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND WE DO HAVE
SOME PROPOSALS THAT ARE ALONG
THOSE LINES. THE DEPARTMENT ARE
THERE SPECIFIC SERVICES YOU CAN
IDENTIFY THAT MAY BE IMPACTED?
BY, SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING CUT IN
ROUND FIVE? WE DON'T WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE $260 MILLION
REDUCTION WILL HAVE ANY IMPACT
ON, AGAIN ON CURRENT SERVICE
LEVELS, BUT HAPPY TO DEFER TO
THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL IF THEY
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION,
YES. AND I THINK I CAUGHT THAT.
SO JUST IF I DIDN'T, PLEASE ASK
ME MORE. BUT THE, THIS 260
MILLION WOULD BE THE SECOND HALF
OF THE HALF FIVE THAT HAS NOT
GONE OUT YET. SO TO YOUR FIRST
POINT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, OUR SPEND
DOWN RATE THERE, WE'LL BE
SHARING THIS DATA WITH ALL OF
YOUR YOUR OFFICES, VERY SHORTLY.
AND, SENT SOME OF THIS ALREADY,
BUT WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD SENSE
OF HOW MUCH HAP ONE, HAP TWO,
HAP THREE, AND HAP FOUR IS
REMAINING, AND UNOBLIGATED. AND
WHAT? THE SPEND DOWN RATE HAS
BEEN THERE, SO, VERY MUCH EXPECT
HAP FIVE TO BE ABLE TO, TO GET
US THROUGH THIS TIME PERIOD
WITHOUT ISSUE AND THAT WE STILL
WILL BE DIRECTING GRANTEES TO
OBLIGATE DOWN THEIR HAP THREE
AND HAP $4, AS WELL. ALL RIGHT,
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE? ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
TAKES US TO ISSUE 24, WHICH IS A
CAPTURE OF ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
FROM ADMINISTRATION OF
HOMELESSNESS GRANT PROGRAMS.
PLEASE PROCEED. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S, JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSED TO REVERT $100.6
MILLION, GENERAL FUND IT.
ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDES FOR
VARIOUS ROUNDS OF HAP AND THE
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGE
GRANTS AS GENERAL FUND SAVINGS.
HOWEVER, AFTER REEVALUATING THE
MAY REVISION, NOW PROPOSES TO
REVERT AN ADDITIONAL $48.4
MILLION IN ADMINISTRATIVE SET
ASIDES AS THESE FUNDS ARE NOT
REQUIRED BY THE ADMINISTRATING
DEPARTMENTS. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. LEO, WE STILL NEED TO
REVIEW ADDITIONAL DETAIL
REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL, BUT AT
FIRST GLANCE, IT SEEMS
REASONABLE, OUR OUR MAIN
OUTSTANDING QUESTION IS IF THIS,
RECAPTURING OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS WOULD
JEOPARDIZE THE OVERSIGHT BY
EITHER THE LEGISLATURE OR THE
ADMINISTRATION. ALL RIGHT. TO
THE SUB. ANY QUESTIONS? ALL
RIGHT. THAT ITEM BE HELD. LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM 25, WHICH IS NEW
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATIONS TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
COUNCIL ON HOMELESSNESS
ACTIVITIES. THE MAYOR REVISION
BUDGET PROPOSES TO PROVIDE THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS $14.8 MILLION IN
2425, $9.5 MILLION IN 2526, $7.8
MILLION IN 2627, AND ONGOING TO
FUND 23 EXISTING PERMANENT STAFF
AND CONTRACTS. KELLY DOES NOT
HAVE SUFFICIENT BUDGET AUTHORITY
TO FUND THESE POSITIONS, WHICH
ARE NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THEIR
STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS. AS
PREVIOUSLY, THESE POSITIONS WERE
FUNDED WITH HOMELESSNESS GRANT
ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDES.
HOWEVER, AS THESE PROGRAMS ARE
TRANSITIONING TO HCD AND NEW
PERMANENT FUNDING SOURCE IS
NECESSARY. ALL RIGHT, GIVEN THE
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITY OF CAL
ICH, THE ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
GENERALLY SEEMS REASONABLE. THAT
SAID, YOUR AGENDA DOES RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT LOOKING FOR
CREATIVE WAYS TO, FIND
ALTERNATIVES TO PAY FOR THESE
WHICH WE THINK ARE WORTH
PURSUING. CAN YOU BREAK OUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS PAID
FOR THROUGH SET ASIDES ALREADY
AND GIVE US A PERSPECTIVE ON ON
WHERE THAT LINE BLURS BETWEEN
HERE AND SEPARATE ALLOCATIONS?
YES, AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THERE'S A THERE IS A
PROPOSAL TO TRANSFER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDES FOR
THESE PROGRAMS OVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, WHICH IS
A NEW ADMINISTRATING
ADMINISTRATIVE BODY FOR THESE,
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PREVIOUSLY AT
CAL H AND STATUTORILY, THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T BELIEVE
IT'S, IS ALLOWABLE TO USE THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDES TO
FUND CAL ACH WHEN THEY'RE NO
LONGER ADMINISTERING THOSE
PROGRAMS. SO AS A CONSEQUENCE,
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TODAY THE
NEED TO FIND OTHER RESOURCES TO
DO THAT TO FUND THEIR OPERATION.
THAT'D BE A MUCH LONGER
DISCUSSION. I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
IT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE. OTHER
QUESTIONS CONCERNS, I DON'T
KNOW. HOPEFULLY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD WILL BE REJOINING US
SHORTLY. FEELING BETTER. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE'LL MOVE.
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN.
THIS WILL BE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE, ISSUE 26.
IT'S DOCKETED FOR DISCUSSION,
BUT THERE IS A RECOMMENDATION ON
IT. ADDITIONAL YEAR STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME FOR THE RECORD AND PROCEED
WHEN READY. GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON. SORRY. ANDREW MARCH
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA AND BY
THE CHAIR, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
THE ENHANCED STATE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT FOR A TOTAL
OF $500 MILLION. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED AMOUNT THAT WOULD
BE, IN CALENDAR YEAR 2025, WHICH
WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY $120
MILLION FOR TOTAL STATE
INVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS OF APPROXIMATELY
$620 MILLION IN 2025. THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT, AS
WE'VE HEARD AND AS THIS HOUSE
HAS HEARD, TESTIMONY ON FROM
STAKEHOLDERS, IS ON THE GROUND,
IS ONE OF THE PRIMARY WAYS THE
STATE CAN, INCENTIVIZE,
CONSTRUCTION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO EXPANDING ACCESS TO THIS
CREDIT, GIVEN THE REDUCTION IN
OTHER ONE TIME FUNDING FROM THE
STATE, MAY MAKE SENSE, IT WILL
COME WITH TRADE OFFS IN THE OUT
YEARS. AND IN TERMS OF DECREASED
REVENUES. HOWEVER. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, 4 OR 5
CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF FUNDING.
SUPPLEMENTALS. I MEAN, SHOULD
THIS BE, AN ONGOING ALLOCATION,
IN YOUR OPINION, ARE WE DOING
THIS ONCE? ONE SEGMENT AT A TIME
AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT? WHAT, IF
ANY, IMPACT IS THERE WITH
RESPECT TO LEVERAGING FEDERAL
DOLLARS? SO TO THE POINT ABOUT
THE ONGOING FUNDING. SO EXISTING
STATUTE REQUIRES THIS FUNDING TO
BE DECIDED IN THE BUDGET EACH
YEAR, SO THIS IS THIS WAS WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
TO NOT INCLUDE IT. AND NOW IT
MAY REVISION. WE ARE INCLUDING
IT. SO IT IS A YEAR BY YEAR
BASIS. AS NOTED BY THE LEO.
THERE ARE REAL COSTS TO THESE
TAX CREDITS, ALTHOUGH THEY DO
MATERIALIZE IN THE OUT YEARS,
WHICH IS GENERALLY OUTSIDE OF
THE, THE CONCERN OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OR THE BUDGET IN
GENERAL, THESE ARE COSTS THAT
OCCUR AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE CAN SPEAK TO ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
LEVERAGING FEDERAL FUNDS. HI,
THIS IS ANTHONY ZITO, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT TCAC, SO, SO PRIOR
TO THE STATE TAX CREDITS, THE
FEDERAL TAX 4% TAX CREDITS AND
TAX EXEMPT BONDS WERE NOT FULLY
UTILIZED. AND THESE STATE TAX
CREDITS, WHEN THEY WERE
INTRODUCED AND ALLOCATED TO US
AND MADE AVAILABLE, THAT FLIPPED
IT, FLIPPED IT WHERE WE WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND, AND WE WERE
ABLE TO FULLY UTILIZE THE,
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS AS WELL AS
THE TAX EXEMPT BONDS, AND IN THE
FOUR YEARS PRIOR TO, THE STATE
CREDIT, WE, WE FUNDED ABOUT 239
NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS,
EQUATING TO ABOUT 22,000 UNITS
AND THEN IN THE FOUR YEARS WITH
THE STATE TAX CREDITS, WE ALMOST
DOUBLED AND DOUBLED THE NUMBER
OF PROJECTS THAT WE AWARDED. AND
WE MORE THAN DOUBLED THE NUMBER
OF UNITS AT 48,000 UNITS IN
THOSE FOUR YEARS. SO IT'S, IT'S
HAD A HUGE IMPACT AND IT REMAINS
CRITICAL, PIECE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE. ALL RIGHT. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR
NILO? JUST QUICK COMMENT, I
THINK, IT WOULD BENEFIT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING GENERALLY
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
PARTICULAR IF WE WERE, RATHER
THAN PROVIDING TAX CREDITS TO
REMOVE MANY OF THE BURDENS ON
BUILDING THAT ADD TO THE COST OF
BASIC BUILDINGS IN THE FIRST
PLACE. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER,
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL ON THIS
MATTER? ALL RIGHT, AGAIN, THIS,
THIS DOES HAVE A RECOMMENDATION.
WE'LL TAKE IT UP DURING THE
COMPONENT OF THE VOTE ITEMS. ALL
RIGHT. CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT,
YOU'RE UP. THANK YOU. CÁC 27.
SHIFTED DEPARTMENT COSTS FROM
GENERAL FUND TO CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT AND LITIGATION FUND.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. BLAIR
OXMAN, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES A $10
MILLION FUND SHIFT IN 20 2425 TO
SHIFT GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
TO A SPECIAL FUND. THIS ONE TIME
SHIFT OF GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT AND LITIGATION FUND
IS FOR THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT, WHICH
IS AUTHORIZED UNDER CURRENT
STATUTE. ALL RIGHT, SEEMS
REASONABLE. HOWEVER, WE WILL BE
LOOKING FURTHER TO ENSURE THAT
THE FUND CAN SUPPORT THIS SHIFT.
ALL RIGHT. QUESTIONS FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE, SENATOR SMALL.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND SO MY
QUESTION IS, WHAT WAS THE
PURPOSE OF THIS FUNDING?
SPEAKING OF THE SPECIAL FUND OR.
YES SO THE PURPOSE OF IN
STATUTE, THE PURPOSE OF THE FUND
IS FOR THE TO OFFSET THE COSTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT TO OFFSET.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE FUND.
OKAY. AND WHY WASN'T THE FUNDING
USED TO ADDRESS? I KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING
THROUGH BACKLOG AND TRYING TO
GET THROUGH THOSE CASES. IS
THERE A REASON WHY THAT FUNDING
CAN'T BE USED TO ALSO SUPPORT
MOVING THAT BACKLOG? THAT'S
LOWERING IT? YEAH IT'S BROAD USE
FOR ANY ACTIVITIES WITH UNDER
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT. SO
GIVEN THE BUDGET SITUATION WE
FEEL IT TO BE A PRUDENT USE OF
THE FUND TO PROVIDE ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS, BUT
CERTAINLY. THAT THERE WOULD COME
A TRADE OFF, POTENTIALLY IF, IF
THE, IF THE CHOICE WAS TO USE
THAT FUNDING TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AT THE
EXPENSE OF GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
AND HOW HAS THE HOW HAVE THESE
DOLLARS BEEN USED IN THE PAST?
SO THE DEPARTMENT HAS AN
EXISTING ANNUAL APPROPRIATION OF
$536,000, GENERALLY FOR
LITIGATION IN. IN THE PAST, THE
FUND HAS BEEN USED TO SUPPORT IT
PROJECTS, AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
AS WELL. OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY CONCERN THAT,
SWITCHING THE USE OF THE FUNDS
MIGHT NOT MOTIVATE THE
DEPARTMENT TO SEEK, ADDITIONAL
OR INCREASED AWARDS OF CASES
THAT ARE PURSUED? SO WE'RE NOT
THE FUND IS A SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. SO IF THERE WERE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT CAME
INTO THE FUND, IT WOULD STILL
HAVE TO BE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE ABLE TO BE USED, SO
OUTSIDE OF THAT, THE $536,000,
IT'S GENERALLY INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET EVERY YEAR, WHICH IS
STILL UP FOR, THE DECISION OF
THE LEGISLATURE EACH EACH
BUDGET, IT WOULD BE UP TO THE,
THE LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE ANY
ADDITIONAL EXPENDITURES THAT MAY
ARISE FROM ADDITIONAL ATTORNEY
FEES OR OTHER, FUNDING THAT'S
INCORPORATED INTO THE FUND. BUT
THE MOTIVATION COULD BE THERE
WITH THE ANTICIPATION OF AN
APPROPRIATION. I WILL TURN TO
THE DEPARTMENT TO SPEAK
GENERALLY ABOUT THEIR LITIGATION
STRATEGY AND THE, CARMEN GIBBS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT, I DON'T I DON'T SEE
THAT HAPPENING WITH US, USING
THAT AS A MOTIVATION. WE DON'T
USE THAT FUND. IT'S FOR
SHORTFALLS. AND SO WE CAN
CONTINUE OUR CURRENT LITIGATION.
SO I DON'T ANTICIPATE AND I
DON'T I WOULD NOT FORESEE THAT
HAPPENING. WE WOULD ASK FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WE WOULD LOOK FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL FEES IN THAT WAY.
THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR. I MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY ON ONE SIDE OF THE
EQUATION, WE'RE SUPPLANTING SOME
GENERAL FUND. IT'S FREEING UP
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS HERE TO THE
TUNE OF 10 MILLION. AND SO THE
FREQUENCY AND UTILITY OF THE
SPECIAL FUND AS IT RESULTS TO
RESULTS FROM SOME OF THE ACTIONS
TAKEN, AWARDS, RECOVERY FEES.
WHAT IS THE TYPICAL EXPENDITURE
PATTERN LOOK LIKE IN OTHER
WORDS, WHAT'S THE IMPACT TO
OPERATIONS ON THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DIVISION PER SE, IF ANY, IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE OVERALL
ENFORCEMENT BUDGET? RIGHT. I GET
THE SAVINGS PART, I GET THAT,
BUT I'M LOOKING AT THE
OPERATIONAL END. SO AS NOTED,
THERE'S AN EXISTING $536,000
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION. THE FUND
WOULD STILL BE ABLE, GIVEN THE
PROJECTIONS, THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THE FUND WOULD STILL BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE
EXPENDITURES. HOWEVER, THE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T UTILIZED THOSE
EXPENDITURE THAT THIS FUND IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS. I BELIEVE
THAT'S WHY I TALKED ABOUT THE
PARALLEL EXPENDITURES OUT OF THE
SPECIAL FUND. RIGHT. BECAUSE WE
CREATED THE FUND AND WE CREATED
FOR A REASON, RIGHT? I MEAN,
IT'S SORT OF IMMATERIAL WHETHER
THERE'S AN ANNUAL ALLOCATION
BUDGET FOR OPERATIONS. WE SAW IT
FIT TO ESTABLISH A FUND FOR A
REASON, OTHERWISE WE WOULDN'T
HAVE ESTABLISHED IT. AND WE ALSO
HAVE SORT FIT IN THE PAST TO
EXPEND FROM THAT FUND. AND SO
THERE IS, IN FACT, A NET IMPACT
ON THE FUND IF WE SUPPLANT THAT,
TO USE THAT TO SUPPLANT GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS. IT'S JUST BASIC
MATH. RIGHT. AND IT'S SO I THINK
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE PATTERN
OF EXPENDITURE OUT OF THAT FUND.
AND HOW IS THAT RELEVANT TO THE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT. HISTORICALLY, WHAT
ARE WE LOSING BY DOING THIS TO
SAVE 10 MILLION BUCKS IN
GENERAL, FUND DOLLARS? THAT'S
PROBABLY THE SIMPLEST WAY OF
ASKING. YES. SO AS NOTED OVER
THE PAST THREE FISCAL YEARS, THE
FUND HASN'T BEEN USED, BUT THE
DEPARTMENT USES THEIR GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION GENERALLY FOR
LITIGATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
DEPARTMENT. SO, I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT ANSWERS SPECIFICALLY TO
YOUR QUESTION, BUT, WE DON'T
EXPECT ANY PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT THERE'S NO
PROPOSED REDUCTION WITH THIS,
WITH THIS ITEM TO REDUCE ANY
GENERAL, ONGOING GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES. SO WHAT ARE THE
SORTS OF THINGS WE EXPECT FROM
THE SPECIAL FUND UNDER THE PAST
TO SUPPORT LITIGATION
ACTIVITIES, FOR EXAMPLE, I'LL
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT TO
SUPPORT ON THE SPECIFICS, BUT I
BELIEVE
EXPERT WITNESS, FEES. BUT THAT'S
ALL WITHIN THE 536 STILL
CONSIDERED. THAT'S OUT. THAT'S
ACCOUNTED FOR GOING FORWARD.
UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE TO
INCREASE THAT ONGOING
APPROPRIATION, THEN, WE PROJECT
THAT THERE WOULD STILL BE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING IN THE FUND
TO FUND THE $536,000 IN THE
PAST, WHEN THE FUND HAS RAN UP A
LARGE BALANCE, IT'S BEEN
UTILIZED. IT WAS UTILIZED, I
BELIEVE, IN 2016, 17, FOR AN Ã
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
FOR A CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
OKAY YOU WANT TO ADD ADDITIONAL
COMMENT? NO, I'LL JUST SAY, FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. CARMEN GIBBS,
THE ONLY KNOWLEDGE I HAVE IS
THAT IN 2016, WE USED IT FOR A
CASE FILING. SUIT OR SOME
CAPACITY LOSS. IF, IN FACT,
THERE'S AN ASSESSMENT FOR
SPECIAL PRIOR. RIGHT. AND WE
HAVE FOR INCREASED INFORMATION
CAPACITY, DISTANCE LEARNING
ANALYTICS THAT WE THE DEPARTMENT
THAT WE'RE SUPPLEMENTING BEYOND
WHAT THE APPLICATION IS ABLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT
CLEAR. BUT THERE IS AN IMPACT.
THERE'S ALWAYS THAT. ABILITY TO
ARTICULATE WHAT THOSE ARE. IT'S
IMPORTANT ON THE POLICY SIDE.
RIGHT. BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT TRANSLATORS
COMMERCENTRE. ALL RIGHT. I JUST
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY WHAT IS
THE SIZE OF THE FUND AND HOW
MUCH DOES IT ACCRUE ANNUALLY?
THE DEPOSITS INTO THE FUND
DEPEND ON LITIGATION FROM FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. SO, THE REVENUE
SOURCE FOR THE FUND ARE ATTORNEY
FEES AND OTHER JUDGMENTS AWARDED
FROM SUCCESSFUL LITIGATION FROM
THE DEPARTMENT, IN SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PROJECT WITH, ANY,
ANY EXACT SCIENCE WHAT THE
REVENUES WILL BE IN THE FUND.
BUT, IN THE MOST RECENT PAST
YEAR, IN 22, 23, THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY $7 MILLION
DEPOSITED INTO THE FUND. I
BELIEVE THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
AN ANOMALY, HERE. BUT THERE'S
WE'RE PROJECTING APPROXIMATELY,
OVER, I THINK 10.5 MILLION. SO
THERE'S STILL PROJECTED TO BE A
FUND BALANCE, AND WHICH WOULD
SUPPORT THIS ONGOING
APPROPRIATION OF $536,000. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND TESTIMONY. WE'LL GO TO
ISSUE 28 EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE MOTION MAY NOT HAVE
HEARD THAT COMPLEX. YES. BLAIR
HUXMAN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
THE CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT IS
RELOCATING ITS HEADQUARTERS
FACILITY TO THE MALEY OFFICE
COMPLEX IN JULY 2024, AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT CURRENTLY
FUNDED TO ACCOMMODATE THE HIGHER
LEASED SPACE COSTS AT THE NEW
FACILITY, THE DEPARTMENT WILL
OCCUPY MORE SQUARE FOOTAGE AT
THE NEW BUILDING THAN AT ITS
EXISTING ELK GROVE ELK GROVE
HEADQUARTERS, AND MAY REVISION
PROPOSES APPROXIMATELY 1.2
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN 2425 TO
PAY FOR THE INCREASE IN RENTAL
COSTS. ALL RIGHT, GUYS, AT THIS
TIME, THIS WOULD BREAK THIS DOWN
FOR ME BECAUSE I NEED THIS TO
BE. ALL RIGHT. SO THE CURRENT
OWNERSHIP FACILITY 1.2 IS OLD.
WHAT AND ARE IN A SITUATION
WHERE ONE STATE ENTITY IS
FAILING TO REGISTER. AND HOW IS
THAT RELEVANT. AND THIS IS A NEW
FACILITY, I'M ASSUMING IT'S PART
OF THE FINANCING, BUT I COULD
BREAK THIS DOWN AS TO WHY WE'RE
WHY THIS IS STRUCTURED AS IT IS.
YEAH, CERTAINLY, SO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY
LEASES A PRIVATE OFFICE SPACE IN
ELK GROVE, THEY'RE NOW MOVING TO
A STATE OWNED FACILITY IN
SACRAMENTO, JUST, NEARBY IN THE
RAIL YARDS, THE MALEY OFFICE
COMPLEX. IT WAS PREVIOUSLY
CALLED THE RICHARDS BOULEVARD
OFFICE COMPLEX. AS WITH ANY
OTHER STATE OWNED, FACILITY,
THEIR LEASE COSTS FOR IT THAT.
AND THE LEASE COSTS PAY THESE
LEASE COSTS PAY FOR THE, THE
OPERATION OF THE BUILDING. SO
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES, FOR THEIR STAFF IN THE
BUILDING AND THE, THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT FOR
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS, THE
ACTUAL COSTS FOR THE BUILDING, I
BELIEVE, ARE CARRIED AS A LEASE
REVENUE BOND ELSEWHERE IN THE
BUDGET. SO THE ACTUAL THIS ISN'T
PAYING FOR THE ACTUAL FACILITY
OF THE BUILDING. THIS IS PAYING
FOR THE OPERATION OF THE
BUILDING. I JUST WANTED TO KNOW,
IS THERE AN ESTIMATION ON WHAT
THE SAVINGS WILL BE? BUOYED BY
SHIFTING FROM A ROAD FACILITY?
SO WITH THIS MOVE, A COUPLE OF
THINGS ARE HAPPENING WHICH, ONE
IS THAT IT'S A NEWER BUILDING,
TWO IS THAT THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT IS ASSUMING MORE
LEASE SPACE THAN THEY CURRENTLY
OCCUPY. AND ELK GROVE, SO
THEREFORE WE ARE NOT EXPECTING
ANY SAVINGS FROM THAT. THIS IS
WHAT THIS IS WHERE THIS
ADDITIONAL $1.1 MILLION REQUEST
IS COMING FROM IS THAT, THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT IS NOT
ABLE TO ABSORB THIS WITHIN THEIR
EXISTING ALLOCATION FOR THEIR
LEASE. SO AND THIS IS LIKE A ONE
TIME, THIS IS JUST WHAT IT WILL
COST ABOVE. SO THIS IS A ONE
TIME PROPOSAL, HOWEVER, THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
IS RESTRUCTURING THEIR RATES.
SO, WE DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
ONGOING FUNDING, BUT WE WILL BE
COMING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
NEXT YEAR FOR ONGOING FUNDING
ONCE THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES HAS RESTRUCTURED THEIR
RATES. AND WE HAVE A GOOD SENSE
OF WHAT THE ONGOING COSTS WILL
BE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? MR. CHAIRMAN? THANK
YOU. TO HOLD THAT, MOVE TO
HOUSING, COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
AND. ISSUE 29. BLAIR HUXMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES A 500.3
MILLION INCHES NEW REDUCTIONS
FOR VARIOUS HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT RECEIVED INVESTMENTS OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS. IN
ADDITION TO THE 1.2 BILLION IN
REDUCTIONS PROPOSED AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A REDUCTION OF
75,000,000 IN 2324 TO THE
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO THE 250 MILLION
PROPOSED AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
THE FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM WAS
INCLUDED IN EARLY ACTION, AND
THE LEGISLATURE REDUCED 20 2425
FUNDING BY 85 MILLION IN APRIL.
MAY REVISION PROPOSES A
REDUCTION OF 236.5 MILLION IN
2324 FOR THE PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO THE 247.5 MILLION
PROPOSED AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET,
THE MAY REVISION ALSO PROPOSES
TO REVERT 25 MILLION
APPROPRIATED IN THE 2023 BUDGET
ACT AND 10 MILLION APPROPRIATED
IN THE 2022 BUDGET ACT. IN
ADDITION TO THE 20 2324 $200
MILLION REVERSION PROPOSED AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM,
FOR A TOTAL REDUCTION OF 235
MILLION, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO REVERT 26.3 MILLION
APPROPRIATED IN 20 2223, FOR THE
VETERANS HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM. IN ADDITION
TO THE 2023 $2,450 MILLION
REVERSION PROPOSED AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, FOR A TOTAL REDUCTION OF
$76.3 MILLION. AND FINALLY, THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO REVERT
40 MILLION APPROPRIATED IN THE
2022 BUDGET ACT AND 87.5 MILLION
APPROPRIATED IN THE 2023 BUDGET
ACT, FOR A TOTAL REDUCTION OF
127.5 MILLION IN 2324 FOR THE
ADAPTIVE REUSE PROGRAM. AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THESE MATTERS. ALL RIGHT. SO
THE PROPOSALS IN THE REVISION
THÀNH GENERALLY PULL BACK, I
THINK ALMOST ALL OF THE
REMAINING ONE TIME FUNDING, IN
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS, AND
THAT'S GENERALLY CONSISTENT WITH
OUR RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LOOK TO THE ONE TIME
FUNDING AS A WAY TO START TO
ADDRESS THE BUDGET PROBLEM, AS
THESE ARE USER LOSE SOLUTIONS.
THAT SAID, THEY DO COME WITH
SIGNIFICANT TRADE OFFS, THERE IS
SOME REMAINING ONE TIME MONEY IN
OTHER AREAS OF THE BUDGET, NOT
NECESSARILY WITHIN THE PURVIEW
OF THIS PARTICULAR SUBCOMMITTEE.
BUT IF THE LEGISLATURE WISHED
TO, IT COULD SWAP OUT SOME OF
THOSE SOLUTIONS. BUT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE LOOK TO ONE TIME
FUNDING TO PULL BACK AS THE
FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING THE
BUDGET PROBLEM. THANK YOU. AND
TO THAT, I'M SORRY. SORRY,
TYRONE BUCKLEY, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LEGISLATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT, JUST HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. GREAT ARE
THERE, WHAT ARE OTHER REMAINING
UNALLOCATED BALANCES AND OTHER
PROGRAMMATIC FUNDS IN HCD, AS
STATED BY THE LEO, THIS THIS,
THE MAY REVISION. I THINK THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FUNDING, IS GENERALLY AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. THERE IS
OTHER FUNDING THAT I THINK IT'S
ALSO LUMPED IN WITH THE
HOMELESSNESS SPACE THAT IS IN
THE, HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
ARENA, BUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FUNDING IS GENERALLY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, THERE'S
BEEN PREVIOUS ALLOCATIONS TO THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY, SPECIFICALLY FOR
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS. THAT
FUNDING IS EXHAUSTED, AND THEN,
AS WE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED, THE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT AT
THE TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE IS THE OTHER SOURCE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING. ON
THE DEPARTMENT SIDE, DO YOU HAVE
TO QUALIFY POTENTIAL MEANINGS
LOST IN THE QUARTER IN OTHER
WORDS, WE WERE TO REJECT WHAT WE
PRODUCE WITH THIS FUNDING. SO WE
DID DO SOME PRELIMINARY
ESTIMATIONS OF, WHAT THE LOSS
WOULD BE FROM THESE REDUCTIONS,
JUST GOING THROUGH THE IMPACTED
PROGRAMS, THE MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM, THE MAY
REVISION HAS A CUT OF $75
MILLION, AND WE ESTIMATE. THAT
THAT WOULD RESULT IN ABOUT 483
UNITS NOT BEING FUNDED FOR
PRODUCTION, ADAPTIVE REUSE
REVERSION PROGRAM. THAT'S A
REDUCTION OF $127.5 MILLION. AND
OUR ESTIMATE THAT'S A THAT'S A
SUPPORTIVE PROGRAM. AND THAT
WOULD PROBABLY HAVE ABOUT THREE,
3315 UNITS NOT SUPPORTED. THEN
WE HAVE THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM,
AND THAT IS A $35 MILLION
REDUCTION. AND THAT WOULD
APPROXIMATELY LEAVE 910 UNITS
UNSUPPORTED, THE VETERANS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAM, THE CUT OF 26.3
MILLION, THAT WOULD LEAVE
APPROXIMATELY 169 UNITS, NOT
FUNDED FOR PRODUCTION, WE'VE
DISCUSSED ALREADY TODAY THE HAT
PROGRAM, THE $260 MILLION
REDUCTION THERE, WE ESTIMATE
THAT APPROXIMATELY 120,000,
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO ACCESS SERVICES THERE,
OVERALL, WE THINK THEY'D
PROBABLY BE A REDUCTION OF ABOUT
5800 TO 6000 UNITS, IF YOU
COUPLE THAT WITH THE JANUARY
REDUCTIONS AS WELL, M-H-P WENT
ALL THE WAY DOWN FROM 325. SO
THAT'S A 2900, 2093 UNITS,
REDUCTION, THE INFRASTRUCTURE,
INFILL GRANT PROGRAM WENT DOWN
FROM 235. THAT'S 7000 UNITS, VP
ALSO WAS A LARGER REDUCTION FROM
THE JANUARY BUDGET. SO THAT'S
490, THE ADAPTIVE REUSE PROGRAM
STAYED THE SAME. THAT'S STILL AT
33,000 OR SO, ULTIMATELY,
PROBABLY BETWEEN THE JANUARY AND
THE MAY REVISE, WE'RE SEEING
PROBABLY A REDUCTION IN ABOUT
12,900 UNITS. SO JUST ONE NOTE
ON THAT. SO TWO PROGRAMS, THE
ADAPTIVE REUSE PROGRAM, THE
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM DON'T DIRECTLY FUND
UNITS, THEY FUND INFRASTRUCTURE
TO ASSIST UNITS. AND THE NUMBERS
QUOTED ARE MARKET RATE UNITS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. SO IF
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION,
THE NUMBER IS GOING TO BE LOWER
THAN WHAT WAS JUST QUOTED. ANY
OTHER CENTERS SAY MORE ABOUT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT
REDUCTIONS. WHAT'S THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE 12,900? I
DON'T HAVE THE BREAKDOWN OF, AND
THE ADAPTIVE REUSE SUPPORTIVE
PROGRAMS, BUT I CAN GET THAT FOR
YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. IS SHE 30? MR. STAFFORD?
LAWCENTER MELMASON. NO. AS LONG
AS IT'S USED.
PLEASE PROCEED. WE'RE READY,
BLAIR HUXMAN, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT NEW
POSITION AUTHORITY FOR 13
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS IN 2024, 25
AND ONGOING TO INTEGRATE AND
ADMINISTER THE CATHOLIC
HOMELESSNESS GRANT PROGRAMS, AS
WELL AS BUILD OUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESULTS PARTNERSHIP UNIT. THESE
13 POSITIONS ARE IN ADDITION TO
THE FOUR POSITIONS REQUESTED AT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, FOR A
TOTAL OF 17 POSITIONS IN 2024,
25 AND ONGOING. OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE STATE'S
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN A KEY PRIORITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE. THAT SAID,
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS NOT
YET FULLY FLESHED OUT, SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE FURTHER
DETAILS BEFORE WE AND FURTHER
AFTER TRANSFER, IS IT IS THIS
COMPLEX CONSTANT, 100,
ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDES IN THE
SYSTEM PROGRAM? BUT WAS THERE
ANY FUNDING BACK AND THEN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT? I THINK WE
UNDERSTAND THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THE SELECTED USE, WHICH OVER
TIME, OF COURSE, MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT SCHULER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. SO, THE INCREASE IS
DUE TO A COUPLE OF REASONS, ONE
OF WHICH IS THE SUPPORT
RESOURCES FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE PROGRAMS OVER AT THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL FOR
HOMELESSNESS WERE ADMINISTERED
BY OTHER OUR GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES. SO THROUGH, BUSINESS,
CONSUMER AND SERVICE HOUSING
AGENCY, THEY, ENGAGE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES, SUCH AS CONTRACTING
HUMAN RESOURCES. THERE'S ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT THAT PERFORMS
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT.
THOSE POSITIONS. THEY DON'T HAVE
POSITIONS. THEY ENGAGE IN
CONTRACTS FOR THAT WORK. SO AS
THE PROGRAM IS TRANSFERRED TO
HCD, WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY IN
ORDER TO ADMINISTRATIVELY
SUPPORT OF PROGRAM. SO GIVEN THE
NEW CONTRACTING CAL ACH DOESN'T
HAVE THE POSITIONS TO TRANSFER
TO THE DEPARTMENT. THEREFORE, WE
ARE REQUESTING THE POSITIONS TO
COME DOWN TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SET ASIDE TO COVER THAT WIDE
RANGE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITY. PART OF THAT IS ALSO
IN RESPONSE TO BOLSTER THE
ABILITY OF PROGRAM TO PERFORM,
SPECIFICALLY, INCREASE IN LEGAL
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST THE PROGRAM ACROSS A WIDE
RANGE OF ACTIVITY, WE HAVE TO
KNOW, WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
OF PROGRAM OUTCOMES THAT
SOMETIMES CAN LEAD TO
ENFORCEMENT. SO WE SEE A REAL
NEED THERE TO BOLSTER THAT
ACTIVITY WITHIN THE COUNTY.
OKAY. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE SUBSTANCE.
STILL A LITTLE UNCLEAR AS TO
EXACTLY WHAT THESE FOLKS WILL
DO. AND OUTCOMES THAT THEY WILL
PRODUCE. BUT, AT THAT POINT
ASIDE FOR A MOMENT, ONE THING
THAT THE RECENT AUDIT SHOWED WAS
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF TRUE
ACCOUNTABILITY, TRACKING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH REGARD TO
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. AND, I'VE
HAD A FEW DISCUSSIONS WITH
REGARD TO THIS POINT. IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT SINCE THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED, CAL HCA, ACH, AND
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS NOW
TRANSFERRED TO ANOTHER AGENCY,
WE HAVE TWO AGENCIES, AND THE
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
WE HAVE SPENT ON THESE PROGRAMS
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A STRUCTURED
WAY TO REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE, TO AN EXISTING
COMMITTEE, A SPECIAL COMMITTEE,
ON A ON A SPECIFIED PERIODIC
BASIS, A COUPLE, THREE TIMES A
YEAR. WE HAVE LACKED THAT EVER
SINCE CAL ICH WAS ESTABLISHED.
AND I THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS
KIND OF ABDICATED ITS
RESPONSIBILITY FOR INSISTING ON
FEEDBACK OF, OF REAL RESULTS.
THIS. HELLO. MY NAME IS MEGAN
KIRKBY, DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HCD,
AND JUST WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT.
ABSOLUTELY YOU ALL WILL BE
GETTING DATA TODAY ON ALL OF THE
, THE FOUR ROUNDS OF HAP, SORRY,
DATA THAT, WILL BE, PUTTING DATA
ON OUR WEBSITE TOMORROW. SO, AND
BRIEFING ALL OF YOU ON THE THAT
DATA, AND I THINK TO YOUR POINT,
THAT IS VERY MUCH THE INTENT
HERE IS IT TOOK A WHILE TO BUILD
THIS DATA PORTFOLIO, THE EARLY
ROUNDS OF HAP DID NOT REQUIRE
THE PERSON SERVED DATA. AND I
THINK WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND FOR AB 977 TO
ADD IN THAT REQUIREMENT THAT
THERE BE PROGRAM SPECIFIC PERSON
SERVED REPORTING GOING IN, WE
STILL ARE SEEING SOME GRANTEES
STRUGGLE WITH THAT PERSON SERVED
REPORTING OF, YOU KNOW, WHO'S
GETTING THE SERVICES DIRECTLY,
BUT THERE'S BEEN A MASSIVE DATA
EFFORT BY THE ACH. DATA TEAM TO
WORK WITH GRANTEES DIRECTLY, AND
THEN, THEY DID DO SIGNIFICANT
MANUAL REPORTING ENTRY AS WELL
AS BRINGING IN THAT HMMIS DATA
TO GET A MORE COMPLETE SNAPSHOT
OF WHAT HAS BEEN GOING ON
THROUGH HAP ONE THROUGH FOUR,
AND THEN WE'LL BE ABLE TO MOVE
GOING FORWARD, YOU KNOW,
HOPEFULLY OUR GRANTEES WILL
BEGIN TO USE THE HMMIS SYSTEM
MORE EFFECTIVELY, AND THEY'LL BE
ONGOING DASHBOARD. DOES THAT
HAVE, QUARTERLY PUBLIC YOU KNOW,
YOU WON'T NEED TO WAIT FOR US TO
RELEASE DATA THAT WILL JUST BE
AVAILABLE DATA AT ANY TIME,
UPDATED QUARTERLY, BOTH ON THE
PERSON SERVICE SIDE AS WELL AS
ON THE FISCAL SIDE, BUT THAT
THAT WILL ALL BE ON THE WEBSITE
STARTING TOMORROW AND WILL MAKE
THAT DIRECTLY AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAFF AS WELL,
THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND THAT'S
USEFUL. BUT I WANT TO STRESS
WHEN I SAY REPORT BACK, I MEAN,
IN A PUBLIC INFORMATIONAL
HEARING SO THAT IT IS PUBLIC AND
IT CAN BE INTERACTIVE BETWEEN
THE AGENCIES AND THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT. OKAY, ABSOLUTELY.
WE'D BE HAPPY FOR THAT. I JUST I
NOTICED THAT THERE ISN'T A
DOLLAR AMOUNT ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS. IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE ADDING
POSITIONS. I UNDERSTAND THE
MONEY IS SHIFTING FROM FROM ONE
FROM HHC TO AC, BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THERE'S NOT
A NEW ADDITIONAL COST. THAT
YOU'RE INCREASING POSITION.
THAT'S CORRECT. IT'S COMING OUT
OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDE
THAT COMES WITH THE WITH THE HAP
FUNDING. THERE'S A SET
PERCENTAGE TOWARDS
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITY, AND
IT'S WITHIN THAT. AND I WOULD
SAY TOO, IT'S WITHIN THE REDUCED
AMOUNT BECAUSE THAT AMOUNT HAS
BEEN REDUCED. SO THERE'S NOT. SO
ONCE THAT SHIFTS HAPPEN IS
THERE'S ENOUGH FUNDING TO COVER
THE INCREASE IN STAFF, THE
TRANSFER AND THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF. WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER THE
IEC. IS THERE ANY IS THERE AN
ADDITIONAL COST OR IMPACT TO
THAT IN TERMS OF WHEN THAT FUND
IS PROVIDING A SHIFT OVER TO SO,
SO AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED, ON ISSUE
25, THERE'S THE REQUEST IS FOR
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR CAL ACH
TO SUPPORT THEIR STAFF THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
TIED TO THAT ONGOING REQUEST IS
TIED TO THE SHIFTING OF THESE.
YES. YES. AS PART OF THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR, AB 129, IT INCLUDED,
A SHIFT OF HAP FROM CAL ACH TO
HCD AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IMPLEMENTED THE DIRECTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE. SO AS PART OF
THAT, THIS IS A ALL ENCOMPASSING
OF THE STAFF THAT ARE GOING FOR
HCD, AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THERE IS ALSO A PROPOSAL TO
SHIFT STAFF FROM CAL ACH TO HCD.
AND THEN THIS IS THE SECOND PART
OF THAT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF FOR HCD TO
IMPLEMENT. THE HAP GRANTS.
THANKS THANK YOU. AND TAKE US TO
THE FINAL ISSUE, 31IN INCREASE
IN STAFFING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF. BLAIR HUXMAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF 17 PERMANENT
POSITIONS IN 20 2425 FOR HCD TO
IMPLEMENT AND ADMINISTER THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURAL BOND ACT. OF THE
6.38 BILLION ISSUED IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS, HCD WILL
RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY 1.9
BILLION FOR PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. THE REQUESTED RESOURCES
USING ADMINISTRATIVE SET ASIDES
WILL ENABLE HCD TO ACHIEVE THE
WORKLOAD RESULTING FROM AB 531,
INCLUDING NOTICE OF FUNDING,
AVAILABILITY, DEVELOPMENT,
APPLICATION MATERIALS AND
PROGRAM GUIDELINES. ALL RIGHT,
AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA, WE ARE
STILL AWAITING THE DETAIL ON
THIS PROPOSAL. AND TO THAT
BRINGS IT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
THE TASKING, ON THE FEES. THE
REMAINING QUESTIONS. SO UNUSUAL,
BUT IT'S A PRETTY GOOD NUMBER,
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO A QUESTION
WITH RESPECT TO THE CAP ON
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE, WE TACTICS
METHODOLOGY THERE, RESOURCE
EFFICIENCY. SO, FIRST TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CAP, SO THERE'S
ALSO STATUTORY CHANGE, STATUTORY
LANGUAGE TO LIMIT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CAP AT 3, WHICH
IS IN LINE WITH WHAT WAS
ESTIMATED WHEN THE BILL WENT
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR, SO CURRENTLY THE, THE
CURRENTLY STATUTE HAS NO CAP ON
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. SO WE
FEEL IT'S PRUDENT TO INCLUDE
THAT. NOW SO. AND WITH RESPECT
TO THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS AND
THE ACTIVITIES THAT THEY WILL
PERFORM FOR THE WORK, THERE'S A
RAMP UP AS YOU HEARD, 17 TO
BEGIN WITH, IN 26 AT, YOU KNOW,
AT FULL PEAK, I'M JUST GOING TO
COVER WHAT THE FULL PEAK LOOKS
LIKE AND UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
A RAMP UP TO THAT, THERE'LL BE
12 POSITIONS WITHIN OUR PROGRAM
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENTATION
BRANCH, AND THEY'RE REALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR CRAFTING OF THE
PROGRAM. WHILE IT'S BASED
LARGELY ON HOMEKEY, THERE ARE
SOME DIFFERENCES THAT NEED TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR WITHIN PROGRAM
GUIDELINES, WHICH WILL MAKE ITS
WAY THEN INTO A NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY AND
APPLICATION, WHICH THEN IS
HANDLED BY OUR STATE GRANT
STATES GRANTS MANAGEMENT BRANCH
EIGHT POSITIONS IN THAT AREA.
ANOTHER POSITION IN LONDON
CLOSING IN ORDER TO DO ALL OF
THE CLOSING DOCUMENTS THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PROJECTS.
AND THEN A POSITION FOR ASSET
MANAGEMENT AND COMPLIANCE, WHICH
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LONGER
TERM ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COMPLIANCE WORK. AND THEN THERE
ARE A HANDFUL OF, ADMIN
POSITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
AIR IT, BOTH DIRECT AND INDIRECT
SERVICES, NOT ONLY TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM, BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT
THE BASIC NEEDS OF THE EMPLOYEES
THAT WE'RE ADDING. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS? SENATOR
SMALL? OKAY. SO THE 12
POSITIONS, YOU SAID THERE'S A
RAMP UP. SO HOW WHAT'S THE TOP?
WHAT BAR ARE WE GETTING TO OR
REACHING IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS
STARTING WITH 17 OVER 12
POSITIONS TOTAL 12. AND THEN THE
FIRST YEAR IS THE. 17, 17, 12 IN
THAT AREA, THAT'S FULL AT FULL
RATE. OKAY. IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS
ONE. AND THEN, I BELIEVE I
BELIEVE IT'S, I BELIEVE IT'S, I
BELIEVE IT'S THREE, BUT I'LL
HAVE TO I'LL HAVE TO GO BACK.
YES. BUT OVERALL, YES, IN THE
FIRST YEAR THERE ARE 17
POSITIONS. AND THEN IT RAMPS UP
TO A TOTAL OF 27, 27. OKAY
ACROSS THESE DIFFERENT FIVE
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT YOU LAID
OUT, FIVE, FIVE AREAS. OKAY. AND
ALL COVERED UNDER THE FUNDING
THAT IS MOVING OVER. OH. SO THIS
IS A SEPARATE THIS SEPARATE SO
SEPARATE FROM THE FUNDING.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE THERE IS
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THAT COME
WITH THE BOND. SO THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY $2 BILLION OF PROP
ONE, PROP ONE HAD A TOTAL OF
$6.38 BILLION, APPROXIMATELY 2
BILLION OF IT IS A HCD TO
PROVIDE, GENERALLY PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. AND THAT'S
WHAT THESE ARE FOR. OKAY THANKS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS, EVERYONE, FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE'LL MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
DOCKET. IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYONE TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON ITEMS ON THE
DOCKET TODAY. WE'LL WAIT FOR
FOLKS TO GET SETTLED JUST FOR A
LINE AT THE MIC, WHEN I. WHEN I
CALL YOU FORWARD, PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME, WE WILL
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE, PLEASE. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR INPUT AND
PARTICIPATION. WELCOME THANK
YOU. MARK STIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
ALSO SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA, THE SAN
DIEGO HOUSING FEDERATION, THÀNH,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF NONPROFIT HOUSING, THE
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS, AND THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. BUT WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
RESTORING THE 500 MILLION IN LOW
INCOME STATE, LOW INCOME HOUSING
CREDITS, THAT IS THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND QUICKEST WAY TO
GET THE MONEY INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT IS READY, SHOVEL
READY TO BE CONSTRUCTED, WE
WOULD BE EVEN MORE THANKFUL IF
WE TOOK UP THE CHAIR'S
SUGGESTION OF MAYBE MAKING THIS,
RELATIVELY PERMANENT OR FOR A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. THERE'S
ACTUALLY A LOT OF BENEFIT TO THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY, WHICH
SPENDS YEARS PUTTING PROJECTS
TOGETHER, KNOWING THAT THE
RESOURCES WILL BE THERE WHEN
THEY GET TO THAT LINE, WHEN THEY
GET TO THAT GOAL LINE, AND THEN
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE COMMITTEE
IS AT ALL, IT'S AT ALL POSSIBLE.
WE WOULD LOVE FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO RESTORE ANY OF THE MHP
REVERSIONS AS POSSIBLE, IT'S A
TOTAL OF 325 MILLION IN
REVERSIONS SO FAR. YOU'VE HEARD
FROM THE STAFF WHAT THAT MEANS
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF UNITS.
AND THOSE ARE THE MOST DEEPLY
TARGETED AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
WE CAN PRODUCE. SO ANYTHING THAT
WE CAN DO TO REVERSE ANY OF THE
MHP REVERSIONS WOULD BE ALSO
VERY GRATEFUL. THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU, MADAM. MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, MOIRA TOP
HERE ON BEHALF OF, MAYOR TODD
GLORIA, SAN DIEGO, AS WELL AS
THE FULL BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION, WHICH IS THE
COALITION OF MAYORS OF THE 13
LARGEST CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE HERE, CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ISSUES THAT ARE IN AND NOT IN
THE BUDGET THIS YEAR. CERTAINLY,
THE REAP CUT IS CONCERNING TO
ALL 13 MAYORS, BUT WITH RESPECT
TO HAP, I THINK THAT IS PROBABLY
OUR LARGEST CONCERN THAT THAT
REMAINS OUT THERE. THE FACT
THAT, HAP SIX AROUND SIX IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING. THESE
ARE LIFELINE, PROGRAMS THAT WE
PROVIDE TO CONSTITUENTS. THESE
ARE NOT REPLACEABLE PROGRAMS
WITH PROP ONE DOLLARS OR ANY
OTHER. WITHOUT THESE DOLLARS, WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE WOULD DO WITH
SOME OF THESE SHELTERS. AND I IF
I CAN, JUST BECAUSE IT WAS ASKED
ABOUT DATA, I CAN TELL YOU THAT
JUST THE CITY PORTION, WHICH WE
RECEIVE ABOUT A THIRD OF THE HAP
DOLLARS, IN TOTAL, WE HAVE USED
THE DOLLARS TO CREATE 15,720
2000 BEDS. SHELTER BEDS CONNECT
MORE THAN 149,000 PEOPLE WITH
SHELTER, AND GET 42,215
CALIFORNIANS INTO TEMPORARY AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
THANK YOU. ONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. HELLO, MY NAME IS AMY
HINES-IKE AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM BEING
FUNDED AT A MINIMAL LEVEL OF
$237.5 MILLION. AS THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL SUGGESTED THIS PROGRAM
WOULD SUPPORT THE ACQUISITION
AND REHABILITATION OF 1626
HOUSING UNITS IN THE SHORT TERM,
THOSE STABLE AND AFFORDABLE
HOMES WILL BENEFIT NEARLY 5000
INDIVIDUALS IN THE LONG TERM,
AFFORDABILITY MECHANISMS WITH
FIT FUNDS MEAN THAT EACH FIT
FUNDED UNIT WOULD SERVE MULTIPLE
FAMILIES OVER 99 YEARS, WOULD
SUPPORT THE STABILIZATION OF
20,000 UNITS OF HOUSING AND OVER
60,000 CALIFORNIANS AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRESERVATION
IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE AT
276,000 TO $480,000 PER UNIT
VERSUS NEW CONSTRUCTION, WHICH
IS UP 480,000 TO $1 MILLION PER
UNIT. WE STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT
YOU UPHOLD THE JANUARY PROPOSAL
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
NOT THE MAY REVISE. PLEASE
REJECT THE MAY REVISE. THANK
YOU. YOU CHAIR MEMBER NICK ROMO
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS, CAL COG. AND TODAY,
ON BEHALF OF MTC ABAG, WE
LIFTING UP THE REAP 2.0 PROGRAM,
THE GOVERNOR MAY REVISE
CONTINUES THE CUT OF 300
MILLION. YOU HEARD FROM THE
PANELISTS TODAY ABOUT THE UNITS,
THE REPROGRAM HAS VERY REAL
PROJECTS, HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF PROJECTS WITH THOUSANDS OF
UNITS THAT ARE READY TO GO. SO
WE URGE, THE LEGISLATURE TO
REJECT THAT CUT. WE STAND READY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO CONTINUE
THE PROGRAM AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
CONTINUES TO GO, IN THIS
CRITICAL YEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
. GOOD AFTERNOON, CAROLINE
GRINDER, ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, OUR CITIES
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROPOSED REDUCTION OF $260
MILLION IN HAP BONUS FUNDS AND
ALSO ABOUT THE FAILURE TO INVEST
IN HAP ROUND SIX, AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED, CITIES ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE BEEN INVESTING THOSE
FUNDS IN SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS. AND WE FEEL
THAT NOT FUNDING HAP BROWN SIX
IS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
THOSE PROGRAMS, SO AT THIS TIME,
WE'RE SEEKING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE, RESTORE FUNDING FOR
HAP ROUND SIX AT A MINIMUM OF $1
BILLION AND THEN ALSO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE NEED
FOR ONGOING FUNDING TO SUPPORT
CITIES IN THEIR LONG TERM
PLANNING EFFORTS. A RECENT
SURVEY OF CAL CITIES MEMBERSHIP
SHOWED THAT LACK OF ONGOING
FUNDING IS OVERWHELMINGLY AGREED
TO, AS ONE OF THE TOP BARRIERS
IN ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
OUR COMMUNITIES, SO DEFINITELY
WANT TO KEEP THOSE CONVERSATIONS
MOVING FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS AROUND
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, KIRK BLACKBURN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS, OR
SANDAG. SANDAG IS DEEPLY
CONCERNED WITH THE PROPOSED CUTS
TO REAP 2.0, AS DOING SO WILL
ONLY EXACERBATE THE STATE'S
CLIMATE AND HOUSING CRISES.
SANDAG HAS ALREADY AWARDED OVER
$12 MILLION TO 15 JURISDICTIONS
FOR HOUSING PROJECTS, INCLUDING
FOR CAPITAL AND PLANNING.
ADDITIONALLY, THE THEY'RE
PLANNING ON USING REAP FUNDS TO
FOR VARIOUS OTHER HOUSING
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING TO
COLLABORATE WITH TRIBES AND TO
PROVIDE OVER 600 HOMES IN SOUTH
COUNTY TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. ALL SAID SANDAG WAS
PLANNING ON USING THESE FUNDS TO
LEVERAGE OVER 22 MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL NON STATE FUNDING, SO
I URGE YOU TO PRESERVE THIS
FUNDING AMOUNT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, JOHN MOFFATT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION HERE,
COMMENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER 13, I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO LEVEL
SET ON WHAT THIS IS. THIS IS NOT
A SUBSIDY AS IT WAS
CHARACTERIZED. THIS IS A REFUND
OF OVERPAID SALES TAX ON A
VEHICLE PURCHASE. THE EXAMPLES
PROVIDED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NUMBER
TWO IS INAPPLICABLE BECAUSE THAT
WAS PAID IN FULL. THERE'S NO TAX
CREDIT ALLOWABLE ON THAT
TRANSACTION. IN NUMBER THREE, A
VEHICLE SOLD AT A AT A SELLING
PRICE FULL TAX IS PAID WHEN THAT
VEHICLE IS SOLD. IT USED TO BE
WITH EVERY PAYMENT THAT WAS
MADE, SALES TAX WAS REMITTED TO
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
STATES CAME IN AND SAID NO, WE
WANT ALL OF OUR SALES TAX UP
FRONT. WHEN THAT LOAN IS
DEFAULTED, THE VEHICLE IS
RESOLD. THE DIFFERENCE THERE,
IT'S THE OVERPAID SALES TAX ON
THAT DIFFERENCE THAT IS
REFUNDED. AS PART OF THIS CREDIT
MECHANISM. AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE FINANCING
TRANSACTION, THÀNH OF GETTING
FOLKS INTO NEW VEHICLES, GETTING
FOLKS INTO ZEVS, AND ALL THE
OTHER REASONS THAT MY COLLEAGUES
BEHIND ME ARE GOING TO GOING TO
TELL YOU ABOUT, SINCE I THINK
I'M OUT OF TIME. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. EDUARDO
MARTINEZ HERE WITH TOYOTA NORTH
AMERICA. ALSO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION
, WHICH IS ULTIMATELY A SYSTEM
TO ENSURE THAT TAXES ARE PAID ON
THE ACTUAL PURCHASE PRICE
RECEIVED, THIS THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD EFFECTIVELY RESULT IN A
TAX INCREASE ON THESE BUSINESSES
, WE BELIEVE THAT REMOVING THIS
DEDUCTION WOULD LIKELY INCREASE
LEAD TO INCREASED CREDIT COSTS,
PARTICULARLY IMPACTING CUSTOMERS
AT THE MARGINS OF CREDITWORTHY
CREDIT WORTHINESS. OFTENTIMES,
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS, THIS IS
GOING TO EXACERBATE THE
DISPARITIES BETWEEN CUSTOMERS
WHO FINANCE VEHICLES AND THOSE
WHO LEASE, WE'RE ALSO VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS, HOW THIS
PROPOSAL COULD IMPACT THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS,
PARTICULARLY THE TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES BY 2035,
INCREASING THE COST OF CREDIT
FOR EVS CREATES UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS FOR THESE CONSUMERS
WISHING TO TRANSITION, AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE STATE FINDS
ITSELF IN A IN A FISCAL
PREDICAMENT HERE. WE ARE WORKING
ON OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT
ACTUALLY COULD HELP, REALIZE,
IMMEDIATE STATE SAVINGS WHILE
PRESERVING THE ABILITY FOR
BUSINESSES TO ONLY PAY TAXES. ON
WHAT? ON THE PURCHASE THAT WAS
ACTUALLY MADE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. CLIFF
COSTA, TODAY, ON BEHALF OF
GENERAL MOTORS, I WANT TO ECHO
MY COMMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS, AND THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO
SAY IS, IS THERE IS NOT A
REALIZED GAIN PRESENTLY WITH
THIS BAD DEBT PROPOSAL FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR. AS MY THE PRIOR
SPEAKER MENTIONED, WE'RE TRYING
TO COME UP WITH A WAY AND SOME
OPTIONS TO HELP THE STATE. NOW,
SINCE THE FISCAL NEED IS NOW AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT BOTH THE AUDITING SIDE
ASSOCIATED WITH HAVING TO REVIEW
THESE REFUNDS, AS WELL AS
HOPEFULLY KEEPING THESE OPTIONS
GOING FORWARD. AND SO I WOULD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MELISSA WERNER HERE
ON BEHALF OF HONDA TODAY,
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF THE
THREE GENTLEMEN BEFORE ME, ALSO
IN OPPOSITION TO THE ELIMINATION
OF THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIRMAN. JOHN VALENCIA HERE ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT, ALUMINA
INCORPORATED, IT IS A LEADER IN
GENOMIC SEQUENCING ON A GLOBAL
BASIS, SOME 4000 OF OUR
EMPLOYEES WORK IN SAN DIEGO OUT
OF A GLOBAL WORKFORCE OF 8500
AND SEVERAL HUNDRED MORE WORK IN
SENATOR WAHAB'S DISTRICT IN
HAYWARD AND SENATOR BECKER'S
DISTRICT IN FOSTER CITY. WE URGE
YOUR REJECTION OF ITEM 14, THE
SUSPENSION OF KNOLL AND R&D, FOR
A VERY SIMPLE REASON. THE MOMENT
THAT THIS ISSUE WAS ANNOUNCED
AND SURFACED, CONTINGENCY
PLANNING BEGAN INSIDE OUR
CORPORATION. IT IS PLANNING ON
THE CONTINGENCY OF AN ENACTMENT
VIA A SLOW UP IN HIRING, A SLOW
UP IN CAPITAL INVESTMENT, AND A
REEVALUATION OF THE
SUPPORTABILITY OF ITS EXISTING
EMPLOYEE BASE. ON THAT BASIS, WE
WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
ITEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. GRACIELA CASTILLO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM, ALL HOME AND ALSO
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS,
JUST WANTED TO SAY WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL TO SEE THE RESTORATION
OF THE 500 MILLION FOR LIGHT
TECH PROJECTS. HOWEVER, AS THE
STAFF ANALYSIS POINTS OUT, WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT,
ESPECIALLY IN M-H-P, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO SEE THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT ARE SO
CRITICALLY NEEDED. AND SO ON ONE
HAND, WE HAVE WE ARE BASICALLY
SEEING ALL OF THE GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT GOING AWAY FOR THIS
BUDGET, AND WE ALSO DON'T HAVE A
HOUSING BOND THAT IS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED TO MOVE FORWARD. WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED THAT ALL OF THE
PROGRESS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
ADDITIONAL PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS COMES TO
FRUITION, THAT IS JUST GOING TO
GO BY THE WAYSIDE. SO WE HOPE
THAT WE EITHER GET ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND
OR HOPEFULLY A HOUSING BOND.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. DANIEL PEARL,
ON BEHALF OF AFSCME, WE JUST
WANTED TO VOICE OUR CONCERN WITH
ISSUE 22 ABOUT THE OMISSION OF
FUNDING FOR THE VEHICLE
LICENSING FEE SHORTFALL, WHICH
COULD LIKELY IMPACT THE BUDGETS
AND WORKFORCE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON FINDING
SOLUTIONS TO THESE ISSUES. THANK
YOU. HELLO, SAM WILKINSON WITH
GRAYSON AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS THE CALI
EITC COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
MATCH THE INCOME THRESHOLDS
BETWEEN OUR STATE'S ANTI-POVERTY
TAX CREDITS, THE EITC, THE CTC
AND THE FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT,
AND WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
RESTORE THE FULL 20 MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR FREE TAX
PREPARATION, ASSISTANCE,
EDUCATION OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT
ENSURES THE ACCESSIBILITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THOSE TAX
CREDITS, AND LASTLY, TO, PURSUE,
REVENUES THAT ARE PROGRESSIVE
AND EQUITABLE, SUCH AS THOSE
OUTLINED BY THE LAO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GOOD EVENING, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. MY NAME IS
VANESSA OROZCO AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY. AND I'M ALSO A
CO-LEAD IN THE CALI EITC
COALITION, WE'RE HERE TO
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN
OUR FUNDING AND CALI EITC
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND FREE
TAX PREP, IT WOULD BE REALLY
HARD FOR THE STATE TO TRY TO
REPLICATE THE ONE ON ONE SUPPORT
THAT WE GIVE OUR PARTICIPANTS
CGRTS AND, EDUCATE. THAT
INCLUDES EDUCATING THEM ON HOW
TO CLAIM THE TAX CREDITS AND
FREE TAX PREP SERVICES WILL BE
SCALED BACK AT THE EXPENSE OF
THESE FAMILIES AND THE LOCAL
ECONOMY. SO WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO MAINTAIN THE FUNDING. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, COMMITTEE
CHAIR MEMBERS ETHAN NAGLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF BELMONT,
REDWOOD CITY, FOSTER CITY AND
THE TOWN OF HILLSBOROUGH, THE
VFL BACKFILL AGREEMENT IS AN
ESSENTIAL REVENUE SOURCE FOR
LOCAL ANNUAL OPERATING BUDGETS
THAT SUPPORTS VITAL COMMUNITY
SERVICES IN BELMONT. THESE FUNDS
ARE USED TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
SAFETY, INCLUDING POLICE, FIRE
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
MAINTENANCE. IN REDWOOD CITY, A
CUT OF THE 3.3 MILLION Dð
TRANSLATES TO A LOSS OF
FINANCING FOR 20% OF THE CITY'S
FIREFIGHTERS. IN FOSTER CITY,
THE IN-LIEU PAYMENT REPRESENTS
7.5% OF THE GENERAL FUND, AND
FAILURE TO PROVIDE THE FUNDING
WOULD HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON CITY OPERATIONS AS THEY, LIKE
THE STATE, FACE A BALANCING,
FACE, BALANCING STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AGAINST INCREASING
OPERATING COSTS, IN HILLSBORO,
LIBRARIES, PARKS AND RECREATIONS
AND OTHER PARKS AND OTHER PUBLIC
WORKS. REPRESENTS FINANCING FOR
EIGHT MAINTENANCE WORKERS, WE
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR VLF IN LIEU
SHORTFALL FOR SAN MATEO COUNTY
AND ITS 20 CITIES IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET TO ENSURE THESE
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO PRIORITIZE SHARED PRIORITIES
OF ADDRESSING THE HOUSING
CRISIS, CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS WITHOUT A
NEGATIVE IMPACT TO OTHER
ESSENTIAL AND REQUIRED COMMUNITY
SERVICES. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER, BUT AUDREY
RITECHECK, I'M HERE FROM CRUZ
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY, AND WE'RE HERE TO
REQUEST SUPPORT FOR FUNDING OF
THE VLF SHORTFALL AMOUNT FOR OUR
COUNTY FOR $70 MILLION IN THE
CITY'S OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RELY ON THESE FUNDS TO DELIVER
CRITICAL SERVICES TO THEIR
RESIDENTS, FOR WHICH COSTS ARE
RISING. THE STATE ENSURES THAT
EVERY COUNTY AND CITY IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVES THEIR FULL
IN-LIEU VLF AMOUNT REGARDLESS OF
THE AMOUNT, SO THE STATE SHOULD
NOT SINGLE OUT SAN MATEO COUNTY
IN ITS CITIES TO SUFFER A LOSS
OF ESSENTIAL FUNDING BY
DECLINING TO REIMBURSE THIS
SHORTFALL. THE IN-LIEU VLF
PAYMENT IS A SIGNIFICANT CORE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE COUNTY
AND ITS CITIES. FOR THE COUNTY.
IF WE DIDN'T RECEIVE THIS MONEY
THIS YEAR, IT'S APPROXIMATELY
18% OF OUR GENERAL FUND BUDGET.
THAT IS GOES TO A VARIETY OF
SERVICES FOR THE CITIES. THESE
RESPECT PERCENTAGES VARY, BUT
IT'S STILL A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
THE BUDGET FOR ALL OF THESE
CITIES. IT WOULD ALSO BE
CONTRARY TO THE 2004 BUDGET
COMPROMISE IN WHICH THESE
PAYMENTS WERE GUARANTEED BY LAW
IN EXCHANGE FOR SUBSTANTIAL
FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTIONS BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SO FAILURE TO
PROVIDE THE FULL PAYMENT WOULD
BE DEVASTATING TO THE LOCAL
BUDGETS THAT DEPEND ON THESE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
PROVIDING FUNDING TO OFFSET THE
LOSSES OF VLF BACKFILL THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY THE COUNTIES OF SAN
MATEO, ALPINE AND MONO ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF THE COUNTIES OF
ALPINE AND MONO, I DO THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT, THESE COUNTIES AREN'T
GENERALLY LUMPED IN WITH LARGE
URBAN COUNTIES LIKE SAN MATEO.
THEY DO NOT HAVE HIGH WEALTH,
RESIDENTS. THEY DO NOT HAVE HUGE
ASSESSED VALUATIONS. WHAT THEY
HAVE IS VERY FEW KIDS. AND
THAT'S THE REASON THAT THEY'RE
SORT OF IN THIS QUANDARY. AND
THEY'RE VERY LIMITED AMOUNTS
THAT ARE OWED TO THEM ARE HUGE
FOR THEIR BUDGETS BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO SMALL. SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THAT PROPOSAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M ERIC LURIE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. I'M HERE TO DISCUSS
TWO ITEMS, FIRST, I WOULD ALLOW
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY, ALPINE AND MONO,
REGARDING THE VLF BACKFILL
ISSUE, FOR US, THE ISSUE IS NOT
ABOUT FIXING HOLES IN THE
BUDGET, BUT ABOUT HONORING A
PROMISE MADE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DECADES AGO. FOR THE
IMPACTED COUNTIES, THE REVENUE
LOSS IS SIGNIFICANT AND NEEDED
TO DELIVER VITAL SERVICES, AND
WE URGE YOU TO INCLUDE THE
BACKFILL TO THOSE AFFECTED
COUNTIES, THOSE COMMENTS ARE
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES, SECOND, CSAC
IS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
MAYOR. THE CUTS PROPOSED TO THE
HAP PROGRAM, THE 260 MILLION
CUTS AROUND FIVE FUNDING, ALONG
WITH THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR
ROUND SIX, WILL HAVE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS ON LOCAL HOMELESS, LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE EFFORTS.
COUNTIES WILL BE FORCED TO
REDUCE HOUSING SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR THOUSANDS OF
CLIENTS WHO ARE UTILIZING
SERVICES AND RENTAL SUPPORTS TO
STAY HOUSED, NEW ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES ARE JUST BEING PUT IN
EFFECT, AND NOW IS NOT THE TIME
TO PULL BACK ON THE COMMITMENT
TO THIS VITAL FUNDING THAT IS
KEY TO THE STATE'S HOMELESSNESS
EFFORTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS
BUCKLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO, WE'D LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO AND THE
BIG CITY MAYORS COALITION AROUND
THE HAP MONEY IN PARTICULAR.
WE'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE MAINTAINED THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR ROUND
FIVE AND FUND THE ROUND SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD SUSPEND THE
NET OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTIONS
FOR CERTAIN EMPLOYERS, AS WELL
AS A CAP ON THE BUSINESS TAX
CREDIT. IN REGARDS TO THE NOLS,
THAT'S MOST CLOSELY SYNONYMOUS
WITH SILICON VALLEY. TYPICALLY,
THESE TECH COMPANIES WILL
OPERATE AT A DEFICIT FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS BEFORE TURNING A
PROFIT. HOWEVER GIVEN THE RECENT
PANDEMIC INDUCED RESTRICTIONS
AND SHUTDOWNS, THERE ARE CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE JUST NOW
UTILIZING THE NOLS TO OFFSET
THEIR LOSSES FROM THOSE YEARS,
PARTICULARLY THE RESTAURANT,
HOSPITALITY AND LODGING
INDUSTRIES, IS EQUALLY AS
TROUBLING AS THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO CAP BUSINESS TAX CREDITS, IN
PARTICULAR, THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT, WHICH
PROPS UP OUR INNOVATION BASED
ECONOMY. CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
PERFORMED MORE THAN $144.5
BILLION WORTH OF R&D ACTIVITIES
IN 2018, WHICH WAS NEARLY FIVE
TIMES AS MUCH AS THE SECOND
RANKED STATE FOR INDUSTRY
INVESTMENT IN R&D. THAT ACTIVITY
TOOK PLACE IN LARGE PART IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE R&D
TAX CREDIT. ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE, THIS CREDIT NOT ONLY
APPLIES TO R&D ACTIVITIES, BUT
ALSO TO THE WAGES PAID TO THOSE
ENGAGED IN RESEARCH OR DIRECTLY
SUPERVISING AND SUPPORTING THE
RESEARCH ACTIVITIES. SO JOBS IN
THAT SECTOR ARE VITAL AND RELY
ON THAT. FOR THESE REASONS,
WE'RE OPPOSED. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS. LANCE HASTINGS,
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION HERE TO OPPOSE THE
NET OPERATING LOSS CHANGES THAT
ARE RECOMMENDED, AS WELL AS THE
R&D TAX CREDIT. AMONG THE OTHER
BUSINESS TAX CREDITS. THE
GOVERNOR RECENTLY IDENTIFIED THE
PEAKS AND VALLEYS OF THE REVENUE
THAT COMES INTO THE STATE. THE
BEST WAY TO ADDRESS THAT IS TO
HAVE A STRONG ECONOMY, AND
MANUFACTURING IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE ECONOMY, SO OUR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO PLAN YEARS
OUT AS OPPOSED TO MONTHS OUT IS
CRITICAL. AND BY SWITCHING TAX
POLICIES AND OPPORTUNITIES
REALLY CUTS UNDER, THE TIDE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING THOUGHT LEADERS
WITH OUR INNOVATION BIOTECH AND
AEROSPACE, ETC. SO WE'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME MORE CONSISTENCY OVER
THE YEARS. AND I THINK THAT THE
ECONOMIC RESPONSE FROM THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR WOULD BE
VERY BENEFICIAL TO THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LAWRENCE
GORDON, ON BEHALF OF THE
AEROSPACE AND DEFENSE ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE SUSPENSION OF
NET OPERATING AND NET OPERATING
LOSS DEDUCTIONS, AS WELL AS THE
LIMITATION OF BUSINESS TAX
CREDITS, ECHOING SOME OF THE
REASONS STATED BY THE
MANUFACTURERS AND THE CAL
CHAMBER AS WELL, BOTH KEY
INCENTIVES FOR THE GROWTH AND
PRODUCTION OF THE AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAMERON DIMITRI,
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY, I'M GOING
TO SPEAK ON TWO DIFFERENT
ISSUES, AND THE FIRST WILL BE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES AND BIO INNOVATION
ORGANIZATION, REPRESENTING ABOUT
13,000 LIFE SCIENCE COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH R&D IN ALL AREAS
OF BIOTECHNOLOGY, INCLUDING
PHARMACEUTICALS, MEDICAL DEVICES
AND TECHNOLOGY, AND INNOVATIONS
IN AG, CLS AND BIO ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL, WHICH SUSPENDS
THE NET OPERATING LOSS AND THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDITS FOR LIFE SCIENCES
COMPANIES SUSPENDING THESE TAX
CREDITS FOR LIFE SCIENCE
COMPANIES WILL DO MORE TO HARM
OUR ECONOMY THAN IT WILL TO HELP
, AND IT IS ACTUALLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO C¢M
ECONOMIC RESILIENCY IN THE LONG
TERM. WE REPRESENT ABOUT 441,000
INDIVIDUALS. AN AVERAGE ANNUAL
WAGE OF ABOUT $130,000. THESE
ARE GREAT JOBS. WE WOULD ASK
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND KEEP THE
NOL AND R&D TAX CREDIT INTACT,
SECOND, THE BAD DEBT SETTLEMENT.
THIS IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. WE'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG OPPOSITION,
OAN AND CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
THE BAD DEBT DEDUCTIONS FROM
SALES TAX COLLECTIONS. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ONLY INCREASE THE
COST OF CREDIT. Þ CRA WOULD ASK
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL. APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
JOHN WINGER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION, WHERE THE NATIONAL
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
MEDICAL DEVICE INDUSTRY ALSO
OPPOSED TO ISSUE 14, THE NET
OPERATING LOSS IN THE BUSINESS
TAX CREDIT SUSPENSION, IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I'LL JUST
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES. THIS
IS A CRITICAL, PROGRAM AND TOOLS
FOR THE MEDICAL DEVICE INDUSTRY
IN THE STATE. AND SO WE'D ASK
YOU TO CONSIDER REJECTING IT.
THANK YOU. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SUBCOMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TANA
OPPLIGER. I'M WITH CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET OR
CURB, AS WE ALL KNOW, THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE IS FACING CUTS TO
VITAL PROGRAMS LIKE HARP, WHICH
IS SLATED TO BE CUT BY $260
MILLION THIS YEAR. PROGRAMS LIKE
HARP THAT RAISE PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES OUT OF CRISIS ARE IN
PERIL. MEANWHILE OVER IN SUB
FIVE PRISONS AND JAILS, WHICH
EXTRACT FROM AND DEGRADE
COMMUNITIES ARE REMAINING
LARGELY UNTOUCHED. IN THE MAY
REVISION, HARP AND OTHER VITAL
PROGRAMS COULD BE SAVED IF THE
STATE FOLLOWED THE LAWS
RECOMMENDATION OF CLOSING FIVE
PRISONS, WHICH COULD SAVE $1
BILLION PER YEAR AND COULD OPEN
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
REPURPOSING OF PRISON
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH WE
APPRECIATE. SENATOR PADILLA'S
PAST ADVOCACY FOR SAU, AND WE
URGE YOU TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
ELIMINATION OF EXCESS PRISON
CAPACITY IN ORDER TO PROTECT
HOUSING PROGRAMS WHICH, AS WE
KNOW, PREVENT CRIMINALIZED
BEHAVIOR AS WELL AND PREVENT
INCREASED INCARCERATION AND KEEP
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE. THANK YOU.
HELLO. ON AGENDA ITEM 14, I'M
CLAIRE CONLON WITH BIOCOM,
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING 1800
BIOTECHNOLOGY AND PHARMACEUTICAL
MEDICAL DEVICE COMPANIES AND
THEN RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS.
ASKING YOU TO PRESERVE THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT AND NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTIONS. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DRAMATICALLY IMPACTS
COMPANIES ABILITY TO INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA BY ESSENTIALLY
RAISING TAXES ON THESE
BUSINESSES BY 16 BILLION OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS, AS OUR
COMPANIES CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
WORLDWIDE INVESTMENT DECISIONS,
THE VOLATILITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
TAX INCENTIVES OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS PRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS.
ENTREPRENEURS PLAN YEARS IN
ADVANCE AND LOOK FOR STABILITY
WITH THE TAX CREDIT LIMITATION.
IN 2020, RESTORATION IN 2022,
AND NOW THIS PROPOSED SUSPENSION
IN CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO STOP THIS
YOYO EFFECT OF TAX INCENTIVES.
IT'S CREATING UNCERTAINTY FOR
INVESTORS. WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WHO
ALREADY HAVE SENT A LETTER
SUPPORTING THE R&D TAX CREDIT,
RECOGNIZING THE VALUE OF HIGH
QUALITY RESEARCH AND THE
RESULTING JOBS. THERE ARE 1.19
MILLION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORTED
BY THE LIFE SCIENCE INDUSTRY IN
THESE JOBS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. CHAIR PADILLA, SENATOR
NILO, MY NAME IS CHRISTINA. BOSS
HAMILTON, AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ECONOMIC SECURITY.
CALIFORNIA ACTION. SO I'M
SPEAKING ON, HOPEFULLY A VERY
SIMPLE BUT EXCITING ISSUE AREA,
WHICH IS FRANCHISE TAX BOARD,
ISSUE 19, REGARDING THE IRS
DIRECT FILE PORTAL. SO IN A YEAR
LIKE THIS WHERE THERE ARE SO
MANY BUDGET CUTS THAT IMPACT
HUMAN SERVICES, HEALTH PROGRAMS,
EDUCATION, ETC, THERE IS A
SIMPLE CHANGE THAT THE STATE CAN
MAKE THAT WILL HELP LOW INCOME
PEOPLE ACCESS EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. WHY CTC, THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT, AND THAT IS LITERALLY
DIRECT FTB TO INTEGRATE CAL FILE
WITH THE FEDERAL DIRECT FILE
BECAUSE THAT MEANS PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE TO GO TO PAYE TAX PREPARERS
TO GET ASSISTANCE ACCESSING LOW
INCOME TAX CREDITS THAT YOU ALL
APPROPRIATE IN THE BUDGET, BUT
PEOPLE DON'T GET BECAUSE A THEY
DON'T KNOW IT EXISTS EXISTS AND
B THEY WIND UP GOING TO A PAID
TAX PREP AND PAYING MORE FOR THE
TAX PREP THAN THE VALUE OF THE
CREDIT THAT THEY WENT THERE TO
GET IT IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO IF
WE KNOW THAT THE DIRECT FILE
SYSTEM FEDERALLY HAS BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL AND FREE FOR PEOPLE
TO GET THIS MONEY THAT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED TO THEM, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA THE SIMPLE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGE, MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE, CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF ACCESS TO
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF TAX
CREDITS. THANK YOU. KIM LEWIS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST, TO MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
FORGET ABOUT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ON THE STREETS, WE
WERE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
SWEEPING OF THE FUNDS FOR HAP
AND THE LACK OF ANOTHER ROUND OF
FUNDING FOR ROUND SIX FOR HAP,
AS WELL AS THEM SWEEPING ALL THE
HOUSING FUNDS. JUST AS ASK YOU
TO CONSIDER ENSURING THAT THERE
IS DOLLARS TO SUPPORT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ON THE STREETS, AND THAT IF WE
COULD PROCEED WITH A BOND FUND,
THAT THERE IS ALSO HOUSING FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY
ELSE WISH TO ADDRESS
SUB-COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC COMMENT?
SEEING NONE ONE NØ ONE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. THAT
WILL TAKE US OVER TO THE VOTE.
WE WILL TAKE THIS IN TWO GROUPS.
THE FIRST ARE, WITH RESPECT TO
ISSUES ONE THROUGH FOUR, ISSUE
SEVEN, ISSUE EIGHT, ISSUE 11,
ISSUE 12. I THINK I GOT THOSE
ALL AND I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. SO MOVE, MOVE BY SENATOR
NILO, IF WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR PADILLA, SENATOR NILO,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK
YOU. THE AYES ARE THREE. THE
NOES ARE ZERO. THOSE ITEMS ARE
OUT. THE SECOND GROUP WILL
CONSIST OF ISSUES FIVE, SIX,
NINE, TEN, AND ISSUE 26. AND
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOVE BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS,
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR PADILLA. AYE.
SENATOR NILO SEN. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. THANK YOU. THE AYES ARE
TWO. NOES ARE ONE. THOSE ITEMS
ARE OUT. THANKS, EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND PARTICIPATION.
IF YOU WANTED TO SUBMIT COMMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE, YOU CAN DO SO
DIRECTLY TO THE COMMITTEE OR ON
THE WEBSITE AT THIS TIME. BUDGET
SUB NUMBER FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND GOVERNMENT
WILL STAND ADJOURNED.